GOOD MORNING I'D LIKE TO CALL
THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
NUMBER TWO ON RESOURCES ENVIRO
PROTECTION AND TRANSPORTATION TO
ORDER WE'RE GONNA CHRISSY THIS
IS SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM I WILL TAKE.
SOME DISCUSSION ITEMS FIRST
WOULD LIKE THIS START WITH A THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL PRESENTATION IF --
I SEE MR INNIS IS [inaudible]
PENDING DEPUTY.
I IN THIS HERE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
COME FOR DISABILITY ITEM NUMBER --
SEVEN YEAH THIS IS THE PROJECT
UPDATE REPORT -- THINGS UP.
L. A. L. THANK YOU.
THIS IS WE HAVE A OUR TOMBS THE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN REPORT IN
THE EARLY A TRAIN OPERATOR
REPORT THANK YOU.
FOR ALLOWING ME NOT TO WATCH
SECOND HALF THE WARRIORS GAME
YESTERDAY SO I GET.
TRY TO GET.
THIS DONE BUT THAT'S THAT'S THE
LIFE I'M LEADING NOW
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
I GOVERNOR NEWSOME IS CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY BUT A PENNY MY
START DATE THERE I COME TO YOU
TODAY STILL AS A SECRETARY
TRANSPORTATION AT THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY.
AND JOINED RIGHT NOW BY A JAMIE
METALLICA WHOSE -- WITH THE HIGH-SPEED RAIL IN THAT THE BUDGET
OFFICER -- THAT COOPERATION
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION HIGH SPEED.
EARLY DEBATES WORDS FOR IT TO BE
IN THAT.
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT SO
HERE WE GO ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
I HAVE N IS YOU MENTIONED
MISTER CHAIR THE TWENTY AT
NINETEEN A PROJECT UPDATE REPORT
TAKING OUT RECENTLY ON MAY MAY
pNEWSOME'S APPROACH TO HIGH SPEED
RAIL.
VISION HE FIRST LAID OUT IN THE
STATE OF THE STATE IN FEBRUARY.
THAT VISION GETS HIGH SPEED RAIL
TRAINS ON THE GROUND AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
LIVES WITHIN OUR FISCAL MEANS
AND REMAINS COMMITTED TO THE
VISION OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
CONNECTING TO THE BAY AREA IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
OBJECT UPDATE REPORT ADDRESSES
STATUTORILY REQUIRED REPORTING
ELEMENTS SUCH AS UPDATES ON COST
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND RISKS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS YEAR'S PROJECT
UP A REPORT INCLUDES INFORMATION
AT THE OF THIRTY COMMITTED TO
INCLUDE AT THE TIME OF LAST
YEAR'S TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS
PLAN.
FIRST THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUSINESS PLAN INDICATED A
FUNDING GAP FOR THE VALLEY TO
VALLEY SEGMENT.
THERE WAS THE COST OF TIME IN
THE PROJECT -- PASSED BETWEEN
YOUR IN MADERA. THIRTY INDICATED
THE TWENTY NINETEEN PER WOULD
INCLUDE AN ANALYSIS OF EARLY
INTERNALIZED RAIL SERVICES IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
SEPARATELY.
ON THE GALLERY TO SAN FRANCISCO
SEGMENT.
THAT ANALYSIS INDICATES THE BEST
SEGMENT FOR EARLY IN ARMS
SERVICE IS THE MERCED
BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT.
THAT SEGMENT WOULD DECREASE
STRIP TIMES BY NINETY TO ONE
HUNDRED MINUTES AND ABOUT DOUBLE
RAIL RIDERSHIP ACROSS ACE THE
SAN JOAQUIN'S.
AND THE NEW HIGH SPEED RAIL
SERVICE.
A SECOND THE EARLY TRAIN
OPERATOR REVIEW THE CAPITAL COST
ESTIMATES AND PERFORMED A
BENCHMARKING EXERCISE.
FOCUSED ON CAST COST CATEGORIES
THAT ARE NOT LOCATION DEPENDENCE
INSIST TUNNELS INVITED AXE.
AND COMPARE THAT TO COST
EXPERIENCE ELSEWHERE IN THE
WORLD AT THAT ANALYSIS SUGGESTS
SOME OPPORTUNITIES FOR COST
SAVINGS WHICH WILL BE FURTHER
EXPLORED DURING PRELIMINARY
ENGINEERING AND FINAL DESIGN
PHASES.
LASTLY OF FORTY COMPLETED A MORE
RIGOROUS RISK EVALUATION AND
MADE UPDATES TO CENTRAL VALLEY
COST ESTIMATES.
THESE ESTIMATES INCREASE THE
CONTINGENCY FROM ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION TO ABOUT ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION.
AND INCLUDED SOME SCOPE
INCREASES.
INCREASING THE PROJECT COST
ABOUT THREE POINT 5% OR THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO MILLION AN
INCREASE AND SOME INCREASES IN
COSTS.
THERE WERE FIVE FOUR POINT 5% OR
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION.
AND THESE INCLUDE ITEMS LIKE
INTRUSION BARRIERS LEGAL
SETTLEMENTS AND TRACKS AND
SYSTEMS.
AS FOR THIS PROJECT UPDATE
REPORT FOCUSES THE EXISTING
FUNDING RESOURCES THE STATE IS
IDENTIFIED TO GET A SECTION OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL UP AND RUNNING.
THEY CAN DEMONSTRATE THE
VIABILITY OF THE BROADER PROJECT
SPECIFICALLY THE REPORT PROPOSES
BUILDING THE MERCED.
FRESNO BAKERSFIELD LINE A
BUILDING BLOCK THAT MATCHES THE
AVAILABLE FUNDS WE HAVE.
AND IS BASED ON THE BEST
INFORMATION WE HAVE TODAY.
THE SAME TIME THE PROJECT AT THE
REPORT MAINTAINS EXISTING
COMMITMENTS TO BOOK AND PROJECTS
IN THE COMPLETION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS.
ON THE ENTIRE SAN FRANCISCO TO
ANAHEIM SEGMENT.
SO WHEN THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
COMPLETED THE STATE WILL HAVE A
VERY SUBSTANTIAL SET OF RAIL
IMPROVEMENTS.
CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION IN THE
BAY AREA ON A FIFTY MILE SEGMENT
INITIALLY IS BY CALTRAIN AND
LATER SHARED WITH HIGH SPEED
RAIL.
THAT INVESTMENT INCREASES SPEEDS
CAPACITY IMPROVE THEIR QUALITY
AND AS SOME STUDY SHOWING CRUZ
IMPROVES PROPERTY VALUES ALONG
THE STATIONS.
CENTRAL VALLEY HIGH SPEED RAIL
INTERIM SERVICE ON A HUNDRED
SEVENTY MY ONE MILE SEGMENT
LINKING THE MAJOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY SOUTHERN
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY CITIES.
GETTING HIGH SPEED TRAINS UP AND
OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA.
AND LASTLY LA UNION STATION.
A RENTER TRACKS AT LA UNION
STATION AND THE ROSECRANS
MARQUARDT GRADE SEPARATION
INCREASING SPEEDS AND CAPACITIES.
THROUGH ALLEY THE TWO LOS
ANGELES INITIALLY BENEFITING
METROLINK AND SURFLINER AMTRAK
BUT LATER SHARED WITH HIGH SPEED
RAIL. TO GOVERNOR NEWSOME REMAIN
SUPPORTIVE OF THE VALLEY TO
VALLEY VISION OF HIGH SPEED -- I
BELIEVE CENTRAL VALLEY BUILDING
BLOCK IS A TANGIBLE NEXT STEP TO
REALIZING THAT VISION. TO MAKE
THE FULL SAN FRANCISCO DALY
ANAHEIM SYSTEM A REALITY WE
FIRST NEED TO BUILD A WORKING
SEGMENT TO DEMONSTRATE HIGH
SPEED RAIL TO CALIFORNIANS.
THIS PROJECT UP THE REPORT ALSO
FULLY EMBRACES THE AUDITOR'S
FINDINGS FROM THE NOVEMBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NOT IT.
AND WE HAVE ADOPTED SIGNIFICAN
TRANSPARENCY OVERSIGHT AND
MANAGEMENT REFORMS AT THE
AUTHORITY.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS ALREADY
MADE PRIDE THE PROJECT MORE
TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE PEOPLE.
BY POSTING CHANGE ORDERS AND
OTHER DOCUMENTS ON THE WEBSITE.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
IT WAS WILL GO TO THE SALLY OHS
PRESENTATION SINCE THEY HAVE IT
AND THEN WE'LL BRING TO OPEN IT
UP -- FOR QUESTIONS I DID WANT
TO INQUIRE IS YOUR OPERATOR THE
ETL.
EARLY TRAIN OPERATOR THEY HERE
TODAY.
I BELIEVE WE DO HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE TODAY YES OKAY.
TO BECAUSE WE MAY HAVE A I HAVE
A QUESTION FOR THEM ON THE EARLY
OPERATION TO PLEASE ELLIE A
LET'S GET THE PRESENTATION.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
HOW INCREASING THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO AS WAS
MENTIONED WE HAVE A HAND OUT
THAT COMPANIES -- ARE REMARKS
TODAY THAT'S AVAILABLE ON THE
WEBSITE AS WELL I'M TO HEAR THAT
PROVIDE SOME BRIEF BACKGROUND ON
THE PROJECT IDENTIFY SOME KEY
FEATURES OF THIS PROJECT UPDATE
REPORT AND ALSO PROVIDE SOME.
KEY ISSUES FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION I'M IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME AND GIVEN THE
COMMITTEES -- EXTENSIVE
FAMILIARITY WITH THIS PROJECT
I'M GONNA SKIP OVER THE
BACKGROUND I'M AND JUMP RIGHT TO
PAGE SEVEN IF THAT -- THAT'S
ACCEPTABLE TO THE COMMITTEE.
I'M THAT WE IDENTIFIED THE KEY
FEATURES OF THE PROJECT UPDATE
REPORT AS WAS MENTIONED BY THE
AUTHORITY -- AT AGE TWENTY SOME
REYES AND BRIEFLY AS WELL ON THE
FIRST IS IT REALLY CHANGES THE
FOCUS OF THE PROJECT AND IT
CHANGES THE FOCUS TYPE.
OF TUMOR SAID TO BAKERSFIELD.
YES -- THE PREVIOUS PLAN FOCUS
MORE ON THE INITIAL CONSTRUCTION
SEGMENT WHICH WAS A SMALLER
SEGMENT BETWEEN MADERA AND
CHAPTER.
THE PLAN ALSO PROPOSES TO BEGIN
INTERIM FIVE SERVICES INTERIM
HIGH SPEED SERVICES ON THAT
MERCED.
FIELD LINE OF THE PREVIOUS PLAN
A PROPOSED INTERIM SERVICES
POTENTIALLY STARTING I'M SAN
FRANCISCO TO GILROY AS WELL AS
ON THE INITIAL CONSTRUCTION
SEGMENT.
I'M SECONDS ARE THE PLAN
INCORPORATES FEEDBACK FROM THIS
EARLY TRAIN OPERATOR WHICH WAS
REFERENCE -- SO BASICALLY -- AS
PART OF THE AUTHORITIES WORK I
THEY CHARGE THAT REALLY TRAIN
OPERATOR WITH LOOKING AT
PROVIDING POTENTIAL INTERIM
SERVICES ON EITHER THAT SAN
FRANCISCO TO GILROY LINE OR THIS
MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD LINE AND
BASED ON A VARIETY OF
ASSUMPTIONS AND THOSE INCLUDED
ON THE COMPLETION OF A RIGHT IF.
CAPITAL PROJECTS AS WELL AS
ESTABLISHING VERY INTEGRATED A
SERVICE WITH EXISTING REAL
PROVIDERS SUCH AS AMTRAK AND THE
EAST CORRIDOR -- EVERY THE ACE
SERVICE I GIVEN THOSE
ASSUMPTIONS THEY FOUND THAT THE
OPTIMAL SERVICE WAS TO DO MERCED
TO BAKERSFIELD.
I NEXT THE PROJECT UPDATE REPORT
REFLECTS HIGHER COST ESTIMATES
THAT WE SAW BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN I SPECIFICALLY THE
PROJECT UPDATE REPORT ESTIMATES
THE BASELINE COST OF
CONSTRUCTING THAT INITIAL
CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT.
I TWELVE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS THIS IS A ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
VERSUS THE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN ESTIMATE -- THERE ARE A
FEW DIFFERENT REASONS FOR THIS
THE THE MOST SIGNIFICANT IS AN
ADJUSTMENT TO THE CONTINGENCY.
AND THE REASON WHY THEY ARE
ADJUSTING WAS CONTINGENCY IS
BECAUSE THEY'RE TAKING A NEW
APPROACH TO SETTING THE
CONTINGENCY AMOUNTS SO BASICALLY
THE CONTINGENCY IS IS SUPPOSED
TO BE SET SUCH THAT.
I'M IN THERE TO GIVE US A LITTLE
BIT OF WIGGLE ROOM -- BECAUSE
THERE'S SOME UNKNOWNS IN IN
CONSTRUCTING SUCH A PROJECT THE
PREVIOUSLY THE WAY THAT THEY
WERE ESTABLISHING THAT
CONTINGENCY WAS -- TO WAS SUCH
THAT.
IF YOU ADDED THE CONTINGENCY AND
YOU CREATED THIS BASE I BUDGET
THE BASELINE.
BUDGET THERE WOULD BE BASICALLY
A 10% CHANCE THAT.
FIND BUDGET.
I'M AND SO IT 90% CHANCE THAT
YOU WOULD GO OVER THAT BASELINE
BUDGET US THEIR REVISING THAT
APPROACH AND NOW THEY ARE.
BASICALLY TAKING THE APPROACH
FOR THIS SMALL THIS PORTION OF
THE LINE A SETTING THAT BE
SIGNED BUDGET SUCH THAT THERE'S
A 70% CHANCE THAT WE'LL STAY
WITHIN THAT BASELINE BUDGET
RATHER THAN A 10% CHANCE.
AND ONLY A 30% CHANCE WILL GO
OVER THAT THAT'S BASED ON THEIR
MODELING.
I'M THERE ARE ALSO SOME OTHER
FACTORS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THAT
COST INCREASE INCLUDING SCOPE
CHANGES AND SOME COST INCREASES.
I'M NEXT IT'S NOTABLE THAT THEY
DON'T PROVIDE THE COST ESTIMATES
FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE PROJECT --
SO THERE'S SOME PORTIONS THAT%
THEY HAVEN'T WE LOOKED AT SINCE
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN PLAN.
AND I THEY ALSO IDENTIFY FUNDING
SORT FUNDING FROM A VARIETY OF
SOURCES THE COMMITTEES I THINK
I'M PRETTY FAMILIAR WITH THESE
INCLUDE CAP AND TRADE FUNDS.
ON THE CONTINUES APPROPRIATION
OF THOSE FUNDS I'M THERE'S
FEDERAL FIND THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS -- AND
THERE'S ALSO PROP ONE A WHICH IS
A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE
FUNDING FOR THE PROJECT.
I BASED ON SOME ASSUMPTIONS ON
CAP AND TRADE REVENUES -- THEY
THEY ESTIMATE THAT THEY HAVE
TWENTY POINT FIVE BILLION TO
TWENTY THREE POINT FIVE BILLION
AVAILABLE -- THEY ASKED ME THIS
IS SUFFICIENT TO DO THAT MERCED
TO BAKERSFIELD LINE AS WELL AS
TO DO THE OTHER COMMITMENTS THAT
THEY TALKED ABOUT THE BOOK AND
PROJECTS PURCHASE TRAINS.
ON THOSE TYPES OF THINGS.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE. NINE
NINE YOU'LL SEE A FIGURE THAT
OUT LAYS OUT BOTH THE FINDING AS
WELL AS THE COST FOR THE PROJECT
[inaudible]
I'M.
SO NEXT THE STM AVAILABILITY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR PHASE ONE
SO BASICALLY THEY THEY ASSUME
THAT THERE'S ENOUGH MONEY TO
COMPLETE THAT MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD MINE IN THOSE
ASSOCIATED COMMITMENTS -- BUT
THERE'S NO -- THERE'S NO
IDENTIFICATION OF FUNDING BEYOND
THAT.
I SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE TEN AND
WE HIGHLIGHT SOME KEY ISSUES
FROM FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION THAT THAT FOLLOW
FROM THOSE THOSE -- KEY ASPECTS
OF THE PLAN.
THE FIRST IS THAT WE BELIEVE
THAT THE SUCCESS OF THE INTERIM
SERVICE DEPENDS ON A VARIETY OF
FACTORS.
SO AS I MENTIONED BEFORE THE
EARLY TRAIN OPERATORS MODELING
REALLY ASSUME THE NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT ASSUME THINGS ABOUT
WHAT CAPITAL PROJECTS WOULD BE
BUILT.
ABOUT SERVE HOW THE OPERATIONS
WOULD BE COORDINATED SO THAT
THEY WOULD INCREASE RIDERSHIP --
SO IF THOSE DON'T COME TO PASS
THEN WE WOULD EXPECT THAT THE
REVENUES AND AT THE RIDERSHIP UP
MIGHT NOT MATERIALIZE THE WAY
THAT THEY EXPECT.
THE SECOND MAJOR ISSUE FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION WE
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT IS THE
ACTUAL PROJECT COSTS A CITY WITH
THIS PROJECT COULD BE HIGHER.
SOME OF THAT IS JUST INTRINSIC
TO DOING A MEGA PROJECT THERE'S
A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY THERE ON
THERE ALSO SOME SPECIFIC
UNCERTAINTIES RELATED TO THIS
PROJECTS PARTLY -- SHOULD
FUNDING THAT MATERIALIZE
SCHEDULES GET PUSHED BACK WE
WOULD EXPECT THAT WOULD HAVE
SOME COST IMPLICATIONS.
I'M AND ADDITIONALLY AS I
MENTIONED THEY TOOK THIS REVISED
BUDGETING APPROACH WERE NOW
THEY'RE TAKING A LESS AGGRESSIVE
APPROACH TO SETTING THAT
BASELINE BUDGET -- WE THINK THAT
MAKES SENSE BUT THEY'RE ONLY
DOING THAT FOR A SEGMENT O THE
PROJECT THEY HAVEN'T -- APPLIED
THAT.
MORE CONSERVATIVE APPROACH TO
THE ENTIRE PROJECT -- IF THEY
DID WE WOULD EXPECT THAT THE
ENTIRE PROJECTS COST WOULD ALSO
INCREASED AND SO WE PROBABLY BE
LOOKING AT SOMETHING BEYOND THE
SEVENTY NINE POINT ONE BILLION --
THAT.
IS IDENTIFIED IN A PLAN.
THIRD IT'S UNCLEAR IF THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO COMPLETE
MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD A PART OF
THIS IS BECAUSE COST INCREASES
COULD OCCUR ON THAT SEGMENT ALSO
SOME OF THE REVENUES MIGHT NOT
MATERIALIZE SO POTENTIALLY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT COULD RESEND
THAT THREE POINT FIVE BILLION OR
PORTION OF THAT THREE POINT.
FIVE BILLION I'M AS THEY HAVE
THREATENED TO DO I UNCLEAR AT
THIS TIME WHETHER THAT WILL
OCCUR THERE'S ALSO SOME
UNCERTAINTY -- NATURALLY WITH
CAP AND TRADE REVENUES AND SO
I'M SHOULD DOES NOT MATERIALIZE
THE WAY THAT THEY'RE EXPECTED
THAT WOULD BE ALSO A RISK THERE.
ON IF YOU TURN TO PAGE ELEVEN WE
CONTINUE WITH OUR ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION -- THE
NEXT ONE IS THAT THERE'S NO
FUNDING PLAN BE BEYOND MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD SO AS I MENTIONED
I'M REALLY THEY THEY FOCUS ON
FINDING THAT THAT MERCED
BAKERSFIELD LINE THEY THEY
ESTIMATE THEY'LL DO THAT BUT
IT'S REALLY UNCLEAR HOW WE WOULD
FIND THE REST OF THE PROJECT.
AND SO IT LIKELY THE GENERAL
FUND WOULD HAVE TO OR SOME OTHER
SIMILAR SOURCE WOULD HAVE TO
COVER A LARGE PORTION OF THOSE
COSTS.
ON THE NEXT ISSUE I TO HIGHLIGHT
HERE IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DOES HAVE OTHER OPTIONS FOR
MOVING FORWARD WE CONTINUE TO
THINK THIS IS A GOOD OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO STEP BACK
YOU GIVEN THEY WERE CHANGING
DIRECTION GIVEN THAT THERE IS
THIS FUNDING GAP.
THINK ABOUT WHAT IT'S PRIORITIES
ARE HOW IT WANTS TO PROCEED WITH
THE PROJECT -- AND REALLY
EVALUATE THOSE DIFFERENT OPTIONS
THAT ARE NOT FULLY EVALUATED IN
THE IN THE PLAN HERE ON THERE
REALLY A WHOLE RANGE OF OF
POTENTIAL OPTIONS THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED.
WE COULD DO A SMALLER SEGMENT WE
COULD DO A BIGGER SEGMENT -- WE
COULD DO YOU -- CONVENTIONAL
DIESEL SERVICE WE COULD DO
ELECTRIFIED SERVICE THAT WAS
LESS HIGH SPEED THERE'S A WHOLE
RANGE ON THEIR PUBLIC TRADEOFFS
ASSOCIATED WITH ALL OF THOSE
APPROACHES.
I'M SO THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
THINGS LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER AND AT CONSIDER.
DISCUSSING WITH THE AUTHORITY
THOSE DIFFERENT OPTIONS.
AND THEN FINALLY ON THE LAST
ISSUE THAT FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION STARTS ON PAGE
TWELVE I'M WE HIGHLIGHT SOME KEY
CONSIDERATIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO TAKE
KEEP IN MIND AS IT EVALUATES.
ANY AND ALL OF THOSE POTENTIAL
OPTIONS.
THE FIRST IS COST FOR THAT
INITIAL CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT AS
I INDICATED -- IS ESTIMATED TO
COST TWELVE POINT FOUR BILLION
AT THIS TIME EXTENSIONS TO
MERCED IN BAKERSFIELD IF YOU
COMBINE THOSE ARE ALMOST ADD
ALMOST ANOTHER FOUR BILLION TO
THE PROJECT.
I'M SUIT THE LEGISLATURE WHEN I
THINK ABOUT THE DIFFERENT COSTS
OF THE DIFFERENT OPTIONS.
ON THE NEXT TO ISSUE AS
TRANSPORTATION BENEFITS SO AGAIN
IT'S LOOKING AT OKAY WELL FOR
EXAMPLE NOT FOR THOSE EXTENSIONS.
CLEARLY THE PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL TRANSPORTATION
BENEFITS ARE THEY SUFFICIENT TO
JUSTIFY ANOTHER FOR YOU KNOW FOR
BILLION DOLLARS AS OF THE KINDS
OF QUESTIONS THE LEGISLATURE'S
GONNA WANT TO WRESTLE WITH.
THE NEXT ISSUE IS THE EFFECT ON
LOCAL COMMUNITIES SO BOTH THE
CONSTRUCTION IMPACTS ON THERE
SOME DISRUPTION TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN MANY CASES AS
WELL AS SOME ECONOMIC.
BENEFITS FROM THE ADDITIONAL
JOBS SO ARE SOME TRADE OFFS
THERE AND AND THE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS WILL PROBABLY HAVE
DIFFERENT -- DIFFERENT THINGS TO
CONSIDER IN THAT RESPECT AS WELL.
AND THEN FINALLY RISKS AND
UNCERTAINTIES THESE ARE -- ALSO
IDENTIFIED IN YOUR AGENDA REALLY
WELL -- BUT THERE VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT RISKS AND
UNCERTAINTIES ASSOCIATED WITH A
DIFFERENT OPTIONS INCLUDE
POTENTIAL AND DIFFERENCES AND
THE AMOUNT OF RISK.
CONSTRUCTION COST INCREASES.
THE MORE I AMBITIOUS THE PROJECT
FOR EXAMPLE PROBABLY HAVE MORE
OF THOSE -- WRISTS OF COST
INCREASES AND ALSO COORDINATION
WITH REAL PROVIDERS AND OTHER
PROVIDERS ARE PROBABLY SOME
RISKS THERE AND THEN COMPLIANCE
WITH PROPOSITION ONE A AND
FEDERAL GRANT REQUIREMENTS ARE
REALLY SOME KEY RISKS AND
UNCERTAINTIES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PROBABLY HAVE TO WAY.
AS IT LOOKS SET ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED APPROACHING
WAYS IT AGAINST OTHER OPTIONS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS.
MEMBERS ARE.
QUESTIONS I DID HAVE A QUESTION
FOR THE YEAR EARLY TRAIN
OPERATOR SECTOR UNITS IF YOU CAN
INVITE THEM UP HERE --
SPECIFICALLY
.
SO MY QUESTION WAS -- STEP TWO
QUESTIONS ONE WAS ON THE
CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION OF THE
PENINSULA WHEN THAT IS COMPLETED
THE ELECTRIFICATION WHICH SHOULD
BE BEFORE.
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT Z. IF
EVERYTHING GOES RIGHT.
WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO RUN TESTS
TRAINS ON THAT ON THAT SEGMENT
OF TO DETERMINE.
THE MAXIMUM SPEED THAT YOU COULD
TRAVEL FROM.
FRANCISCO TO YOUR DANCE STATION
LET'S JUST PUT IT THERE.
SO I SPECIFIC IN THE SECTION OF
THE IDENTIFY YOURSELF FIRST SO
IT'S A MY NAME IS HOLD HIM FOR
YEARS.
I AM THE PROJECT DIRECTOR OF THE
ALLEY TURN A PLATE.
CHAU TALKING ABOUT THE SPEED IN
THE SECTION ON SINCE WE HAVE OLD
SCHOOL ALL THE THE CROSSINGS AND
AND WE HAVE ALL THESE
RESTRICTION IN THESE HIGHLY THEN
SEE AT THESE HIGH ALLEY
POPULATED THE SECTION.
ON SO THE SPEED THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE WILL NOT BE VERY
DIFFERENT TO THE SPEED THAT
CALTRAIN WILL ACHIEVE WHEN
EVERYTHING IS ELECTRIFIED.
SO WE ARE TALKING THAT THE IN
THE SECTION WE COULD POTENTIALLY
CHIEF. ONE HUNDRED AND TEN MILES
PER HOUR.
RIGHT IN OF THESE ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS AND OKAY ECUSA THAN
THE COULD THE QUESTION IS IS
THAT WOULD YOU RUN.
HIGH SPEED RAIL TRAINS DURING
THIS EARLY PERIOD IS A AGAIN THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS NOT GONNA
STOP AT EVERY STOP SO THE SOME
COORDINATION THAT WOULD HAVE TO
OCCUR WERE EVERYTHING WOULD DROP
DOWN AND IT WOULD GO FROM.
HERE DOWN TO I GUESS THE AIRPORT
RIGHT.
THIS IS THE FIRST DURING THESE
AREA IN THE STUDY WE ASSUME THAT
THE HIGHEST PAID SERVICE WILL
STOP.
I WILL HAVE A SERVICE ONLY FOR
STATION FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE
STUDY.
SO WE ASSUME THAT HE WILL STOP
IN DELIVERY.
IN ASH SAN JOSE.
BREAK.
KING IN THESE FOUR STATIONS. TO
THE SEE WHAT WE ARE STREAMING TO
STAND THAT WE'RE GOING TO STOP.
TEAMS WE ARE CHATTING THE
CORRIDOR WITH DICK CALTRAIN --
TO TRAINS.
SO WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO CHIEF --
TAKE HIRES PIZZA IN THE SECTION
THAT THEY WILL ACHIEVE.
AN EVEN THAT THE WHAT TRAINS
WOULD BE FOSTER IN THIS CASE.
I AM WHEN WE DID THE ANALYSIS ON
TO FIND OUT IF IT MAKES SENSE TO
DO ADDERLEY OPERATIONS IN THE
PENINSULA.
WEED OUT THE CONNECTION THROUGH
THE PROJECT COLA TO THE
PARTICULAR PLACE TO THAT TO THE
HIGHEST BEAT.
WE FOUND OUT THAT TERM OUR
SERVICE CAN NO IT'S REALLY BE
VERY DIFFERENT FROM DOES SERVICE.
CALTRAIN WILL HAVE IN A IN.
WE ASSUME THAT WE ASSUME THAT WE
COULD POTENTIALLY OPEN THE
SERVICING TWENTY TWENTY A. FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THE STUDY.
SO WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO REALLY
DIFFERENTIATE FROM THE SERVICE
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE WITHOUT
HAVING THE CONNECTION TO THEM.
TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY. TO MORE
OR LESS FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
INFORMATION AROUND 12% OF THE
PASSENGERS WHICH ARE WILLING TO
TRAVEL IN THE PENINSULA.
FROM ALL THE ALL THE PASSENGERS
ONLY A 112% ARE WILLING TO
TRAVEL BETWEEN THESE FOUR
STATIONS.
SO THE IMPACT THAT WE CAN
CREATING THESE IN THE SECTION.
IT'S NOT A IS NOT SO BIG THAT
MAKE IT SAYS.
I MEAN THAT WE CAN REALLY MAKE
SENSE TO A TO A STAR SOMETHING
BEFORE THE WHOLE THE WHOLE BODY
TO BODY CONNECTION IS DONE.
I CAN NOT MY NEXT QUESTION IS
THAT.
LET'S PRESUME THAT THE MADERA OF
FRESNO SEGMENT GETS COMPLETED
MINUTES THAT THE TRACK IS IT IS
DONE IN THE CONSTRUCTION IS
WORKING ON THE MADERA. TO TO
MERCED IN AN HI KINGS TO LARRY'S
BAKERSFIELD BUT THERE IS A
SEGMENT DONE IS IT YOUR
EXPECTATION THAT YOU WOULD.
BE TESTING TRAINS YOU JUST WAIT
TILL THE WHOLE -- MERCED TO
BREAK A SPELL THE STATE NO WE WE
WE ARE COULD START THEIR SKINNER
WAY BEFORE THE THE WHOLE THE
WHOLE MERCER TRACK TO
BAKERSFIELD.
CONSTRUCTION IS DONE SO WE CAN
START THE TESTING.
WITHOUT WITH A SMALLER SECTION.
ON THE TRAINS WOULD BE TEST OF
COURSE AND THE THEIR TRACKING
SYSTEMS WOULD BE THIRST BEFORE
WE ENTER INTO OCTOBER.
AT REVENUE SERVICE.
EVEN IT'S ALSO A LINE TO THE
NORMAL REQUIREMENTS FOR GETTING
THE CERTIFICATION FOR AND THREE
THE PASSENGER SERVICE.
YOU NEED TO ACHIEVE -- CERTAIN --
MY LISTENS. TO GET THE APPROVAL
TO FRONT ON TO RUN THE TRAINS.
OKAY.
GREAT FROM THERE WAS A QUESTION.
THAT WAS LAID OUT ON THE HEAVY
RELIANCE AT FOR THIS IS FOR THE
SECRETARY AS EVER RELIANCE ON
CONSULTANTS AND THE THE SHIFT TO
MORE -- EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES WITH
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL CAN YOU
ADDRESS -- THAT.
SURE AND THAT THERE WAS
SOMETHING THE STATE AUDITOR HAD
INCLUDED IN THE NOVEMBER REPORT
AS WELL.
AND THERE'S A COUPLE ITEMS HERE
ON THE AGENDA THAT THE TOUCH ON
ON THAT ISSUE -- THERE'S AS
SPRING FINANCE LETTER THAT
REQUESTS TO ADD STATE STAFF AND
DELETE CONSULTING STAFF THAT ARE
REVIEWING SOME OF THE CONTRACT
WORK IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS SO
THAT'S A FURTHER IN YOUR AGENDA.
I WAS JUST TRYING TO GET AN IDEA.
A BIG PICTURE ON A TIMING IS
THIS IS THIS.
A MID YEAR IS THIS. TWENTY ONE
DO YOU THINK THAT YOUR WORK ON
WHAT YOU'VE GOT THESE REQUESTS
AND WE HAVE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
AT LEAST IN THE SECURITY PEOPLE
TO PROVE IT BUT BUT THE IF THERE
IS A MAJOR RESTRUCTURING GOING
ON NOT MAJOR RESTRICTION BUT
RELIANCE ON CONSULTANTS VERSUS
RELIANCE ON AN INTERNAL.
EASE IF IF THE HIGH SPEED ROSE
ALREADY STARTED SOME OF THAT THE
WORK OF AT THE ADVERTISING JOB
DESCRIPTION SO IF THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVES THE THAT
THE FUNDING.
I WILL BE ABLE TO STE START
THOSE AT POSITIONS -- WILL HELP
HOPING IN JULY WHO I GET SOME
PEOPLE ON BOARD FOR THAT TRYING
CHáVEZ.
AND THEN THE BROADER EFFORTS AT
THE CEO'S MANSION LOOKING AT
REALLY OFFICE BY OFFICE DOING AN
EVALUATION TO MAKE SURE THAT.
OF A FORM FITS THE FUNCTION AND
SEEING IF THERE'S OTHER AREAS AS
WELL WHERE IT WOULD BE MORE
APPROPRIATE TO HAVE STATE STAFF
AUGMENTED AND REDUCE THE
CONSULTING RESOURCES AND THAT
WOULD BE.
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE -- WOULD
BE BRING MORE TO YOU PROBABLY
NEXT BUDGET CYCLE -- IT NEXT
YEAR.
CENTER MONNING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN TO GO
BACK TO THE ELECTRIFICATION OF
CALTRAIN FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO
SAN JOSE.
AND THEN.
ANY OF YOU THE OPTION OF
EXTENSION OF THAT CALTRAIN
ELECTRIFICATION FROM SAN JOSE TO
GILROY [inaudible]
SOUNDS LIKE.
HIGH SPEED RAIL [inaudible]
IS GILROY.
SAN JOSE IT BYPASSES MORGAN HILL.
CALTRAIN SERVICE MORGAN HILL --
HAD IS THAT POSSIBLE
ELECTRIFICATION EXTENSION TO
GILROY FIT INTO OPTIONS.
YOU MIGHT BE LOOKING AT IN TERMS
OF PROVIDING MORE IMMEDIATE.
TRAFFIC RELIEF COMMUTER SERVICE.
WITH THE CALTRAIN ROUTE VERSUS
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL [inaudible]
SERVICE.
YEAH LET ME ADDRESS THAT AT THE
F. AT BUSINESS PLAN TALKED ABOUT
LOOKING MORE THOSE AT THOSE
SEGMENTS ON ON THE EITHER SIDE
OF VALLEY TO VALLEY INCLUDING
THE GALLERY TO SAN FRANCISCO SO
THAT WAS.
PART OF THE E. T. O. ANALYSIS --
AS WAS AS WAS MENTIONED BY THE
U. TEO THERE'S SOME WE THINK
THAT MORE SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS
IN THE PRIORITIZATION TO
COMPLETE THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
BUT THAT YOUR A SEGMENT -- HAS
BENEFITS AS WELL SO WE'RE
CONTINUING OUR DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE FREIGHT OPERATOR ON GETTING
MORE ACCESS TO THAT LINE -- AND
THAT WOULD BENEFIT BOTH CALTRAIN
AND ULTIMATELY HIGH SPEED RAIL
SO THE THE EFFORTS CONTINUE TO
TO LOOK AT HOW TO DO THAT BUT I
AS FAR AS THE THE PRIORITIZATION
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT PROJECT
UPDATE REPORTS SUGGEST THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS THE HIGHER
PRIORITY.
AND IS FUND OF ALL WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE.
TO TWENTY THIRTY THANK YOU SO
HOW WOULD YOU.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE THE
STATUS OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITH?
THE REAL PROVIDER FROM SAN JOSE
TO GILROY.
WELL I HAVE WE HAVE HAD I I
THINK WE WERE HAVING IMPROVED A
DISCUSSION SAID THERE WAS A
PERIOD OF YEARS AGO WHERE
DIFFERENT OPPOSITE NO WAY WE
DON'T EVEN WANT TO CONSIDER THIS.
OUR IN DISCUSSIONS ON WHAT TYPE
OF INVESTMENTS YOU KNOW WHAT
WOULD MAKE THAT A CONSIDERATION
FOR THEM AND SO.
THAT.
THOSE ARE AVERAGE DESCRIBED AS
POSITIVE -- WE DO HAVE A SOME
WAYS TO GO BUT AGAIN -- THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE OPEN TO THOSE
DISCUSSIONS NOW AND WE'RE HAVING
DISCUSSIONS ON HOW WE CAN.
JUST AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF
SOUTH AND CLEAR COUNTY.
THERE'S HI PUBLIC INTEREST RATE
IN.
IN A MORE IMMEDIATE TANGIBLE
BENEFITS TO RESIDENTS OF SANTA
CLARA COUNTY SO I JUST.
HOPE YOU'LL KEEP US POSTED OF
PROGRESS ON THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND WANTING TO SELL A HAVE YOU
LOOKED AT THAT AT ALL THE
ELECTRIFICATION FROM SAN JOSE TO
GILROY.
WE HAVE A LOOK AT THAT IN DETAIL --
CERTAINLY AS WAS NOTED THAT'S
NOT CURRENTLY A FOCUS THAT WE
THINK THAT'S THE KIND OF THING
THAT WOULD BE.
APPROPRIATE AS AN OPTION I MEAN
CLEARLY YOU COULD -- YOU COULD
CONSIDER WHETHER YOU WANTED.
TO INCLUDE THAT IN THE PROJECT --
WHETHER YOU WANTED TO INCLUDE
FOR THEIR WORK NORTH ON IN THE
BAY AREA -- OR IF YOU SPEND LESS
MONEY ON THIS PROJECT THAT WOULD
FREE UP MONEY YOU KNOW TO DO
OTHER KINDS OF REGIONAL PROJECTS
SO -- WE HAVEN'T DONE A AND IN
AN IN DEPTH ANALYSIS AT THIS
TIME BUT WE THINK THAT'S THE
KIND OF KIND OF CHOICE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SPACING.
IN IT AGAIN BACK TO THE
ELECTRIFICATION.
AND FRANCISCO TO SANTA IS A THAT
WAS A FEATURE OF THE BALLOT
PROPOSITION THAT CALIFORNIA
VOTERS SUPPORTED NIGHT I DON'T
THINK THERE'S BEEN NECESSARILY.
GOOD PUBLIC EDUCATION THAT THAT
IS ONE OF THE IMMEDIATE BENEFITS
BOTH ENVIRONMENTALLY INTO
CONSUMER -- COMMUTER.
RAIL SERVICE OF THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL BOND -- I THINK.
PEOPLE SHOULD BE REMINDED OF
THAT AT EVERY POSSIBLE TURN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
NOTE THAT.
DE.
EAST BAY THE PORT OF OAKLAND AND
THE RAILROADS ARE IN.
DISCUSSIONS REGARDING ACCESS TO
FROM THE PORT THROUGH THE I
GUESS THE WHERE THE ACE TRAVELS
AND THEN GOING DOWN TO SAN JOSE.
ACROSS THERE SO AT LEAST THE
RAILROAD FOLKS ARE AT THE TABLE
WHICH CANNOT ALWAYS BE SAID THAT
BOX WAS GOING ON TO BE
INTERESTING BECAUSE THAT SAID
THAT CORRIDOR CONTINUES DOWN TO
GILROY.
ON THAT THAT NILES ROUTER WHICH
WHICHEVER THE LINE.
THE LINE IS SO -- AS LONG AS
YOU'RE AT THE TABLE THAT'S THOSE
DISCUSSIONS ARE.
MAKES SENSE CENTER STERN
[inaudible]
FAMOUS CHAIR -- THANK YOU
SECRETARY FOR COMING IN THIS IS
YOUR I GUESS YOUR LAST BUDGET
SERVICE IN YOUR WITH THIS
CURRENT HAD ON SO -- WHILE STILL
GOT YOU.
BEFORE US -- ANY LA -- I WANTED
TO DIG IN A LITTLE BIT ON SOME
OF THE ISSUES RAISED AROUND.
THE LACK OF A FUNDING PLAN.
ON ANYTHING BEYOND MERCED THE
BAKERSFIELD HERE AND WHAT YOU
SORT OF SEE IS THE FUTURE -- NO
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I KNOW
I'M ON A ON A COMMITTEE WITH
MOSTLY MY FRIENDS FROM THE NORTH --
BUT THE BULK OF THE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED IN THIS STATE IN
THE BOOK OF THE TRAFFIC.
WE KNOW WHERE IT IS AND TERMS OF
DISPLACING VEHICLE TRIPS IN THIS
STATE THE CORRIDORS THAT ARE
ANTICIPATED FOR THAT SOUTHERN.
BOOK AND HAVE HUGE VMT
DISPLACEMENT VALUE SO I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT.
STRATEGICALLY HOW DID YOU GUYS
LAND ON THIS SEGMENT.
WAS IT IN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
METRIC THAT STARTED DROVE IT WAS
THERE WAS THERE A METRIC THE
TROUBLE AT ALL WANT TO GET YOUR
FIRST THOUGHTS ON THAT.
BUT IN IN TERMS OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA INVESTMENTS REVISED
TODAY I THINK THE STATE'S ALWAYS
APPROACH THESE NOT AS AN EITHER
OR NOT HIGH SPEED RAIL OR
COMMUTER RAIL AND INTERCITY RAIL
INVESTMENTS BUT BOTH.
AND OF COURSE BECAUSE OF THAT
THE CAP AND TRADE IN THE SP.
ONE AND HIGH SPEED RAIL BOOKENDS
AND MONEY ANOTHER FINDING
THERE'S ABOUT FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION.
IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RAIL
INVESTMENT SINCE.
TWENTY TWELVE SO HAPPY THAT YOU
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS DOWN THERE AS WELL
AS FAR AS THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
ANALYSIS -- THE BOARDED CHOSEN
THE VALLEY TO VALLEY AS THE BEST
APPROACH TO GETTING HIGH SPEED
RAIL UP AND RUNNING.
AND THEN THIS ANALYSIS THAT THE
GAO DID WAS FOCUSED WITHIN THAT
FRAMEWORK OF LOOKING AT THOSE
TWO ENDS OF VALLEY TO VALLEY AND
DETERMINING WHERE'S IN A ROOM
SERVICE.
WE'RE WITH THAT AT BEST BENEFIT
TO STATE.
SO GETTING UP AND RUNNING THAT
WAS THE GOAL TO GET LIKE WHAT'S
THE QUICKEST WAY TO GET YOU SET
UP AND RUNNING.
YES HIGH SPEED RAIL IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT'S WHERE THE
TRAINS CAN GO THE THE FASTEST --
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHERE THAT THE
SPEED THAT'S DEMANDED WITH PROP
ONE A WERE YOU ACHIEVE THOSE
HIGHER SPEEDS BECAUSE OF THAT
THE FLAT AREAS WITH A LOT OF
RURAL AREAS THAT THE TRAINS
GOING THROUGH BUT NOT
NECESSARILY A V. M. T. DRIVEN
ANALYSIS OR AT A DAILY TRIPS.
DISPLACEMENT OR GREENHOUSE GAS
METRIC FOR ABOUT.
THE SPEED AT WHICH YOU CAN GET
TO HIGH SPEED.
WELL I GUESS MULTIPLE
CONSIDERATIONS NOT JUST ONE BUT
CERTAINLY AT LOOKING AT THE AT
THE AT AN INSULAR VERSES THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
THE CHEETOS ANALYSIS WOULD COVER
SOME OF THOSE ITEMS YOU MENTION
YOU KNOWS RIDERSHIP WHAT'S THE
RIDERSHIP GAIN.
YOU KNOW THAT GETS TO YOUR V. M.
T. ISSUE A BED YOU KNOW HOW MANY
NEW WRITERS ARE YOU BRINGING N
TO RAIL.
HAS ALSO THE EMPHASIS ON  AS A
SEGMENT THAT WOULD TEST THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL TRAINS AT THEIR AT
THEIR MAXIMUM SPEED SO.
MULTIPLE CONSIDERATIONS AGAIN
THAT'S THE FOCUS -- CONSISTENT
WITH THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUSINESS PLAN AS LOOKING AT THE
VALLEY TO VALLEY A SEGMENT.
AND AND DO YOU HAVE A SENSE MEAN
PAINT PAINT US IT IS MUCH OF
PICTURES YOU CAN HAR GOING
FORWARD -- I I'M I'M JUST I'M
TROUBLED BY THE LACK OF
CERTAINTY RIGHT NOW AND I I I I
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT GOING ON SO
I I'M.
I JUST WANT.
TO GET GET THIS AIRED OUT BUT I
KNOW THERE'S THERE'S STILL A
FORM SIXTY THREE MILLION DOLLAR
CONTRACT PENDING DOWN SOUTH THAT.
IN THE THERE'S INTENSE BUT NOT
EXECUTION YET UPDATE ON THAT --
I THINK THAT'S IN THE IN IN THE
METROLINK METRO AREA ON THE
BOOKENDS YEAH THEIRINTENDED.
SEE THAT THROUGH EVEN IF IT'S
NOT ARTICULATED IN THIS BUDGET.
LAID OUT HERE -- ABSOLUTELY I
BELIEVE THE TIME THAT THE A LOS
ANGELES UNION STATION PROJECT
ROUNTREE TRACKS AND ABSOLUTELY --
THAT IS STILL -- PART OF THIS AB
FAB PLAN IS.
TO AB IT HERE TO THOSE
COMMITMENTS TO DO THE BOOK AND
PROJECTS CALTRAIN WHICH IS UNDER
CONSTRUCTION ALREADY.
BUT ALSO -- THE FUNDING
AGREEMENT ADD TO ADD A START
FLOWING THE PROP ONE A BOND
FUNDS TO LA UNION STATION WHEN
THAT PROJECT GOES TO
CONSTRUCTION AS WELL HI MINE
SENSE ON THAT BUT I BELIEVE AS
YOU KNOW AS EARLY AS SAID THIS.
LATER THIS CALENDAR YEAR THOSE --
THOSE FUNDING AGREEMENTS NO THIS
FUNDING AGREEMENTS ARE PART OF
THE PROVISIONS OF PROP ONE A
THAT -- WE HAVE AN INDEPENDENT
CONSULTANT LOOK AT THE FUNDING
AGREEMENT AND COME FORWARD WITH
WITH THOSE PLANS SO THOSE ARE.
A ANTICIPATED FOR LATER THIS
CALENDAR YEAR IT HAS TO GO
THROUGH THE THICK THERE'S A
STUDY THAT STILL HAS TO BE DONE --
CONSULTANT ANALYSIS BEFORE YOU
ARE GOING TO SO THE AXIS
PROGRESS FONG CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER.
ACCESS THE PROBLEM A FUNDS WE
HAVE TO DO -- FUNDING FEE PLAN
IN THE FUNDING THE PLANS THAT
ACTUALLY RUNS THROUGH YOUR
OFFICE.
A PART OF THE FUN THE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE FUNDING THE
PLAN IS WE HAVE TO GET AN
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS ON WHETHER
THIS PLAN ACTUALLY MAKES OUT.
AND THAT'S WHAT -- SECONDARY
ADDIS'S REFERRING.
TO SO YOU THERE'S STILL A
DISCRETIONARY DECISION AS TO
WHETHER THAT MAKES SENSE EXACTLY
WE HAVE A THAT HAS NOT BEEN
DECIDED BY.
THE SECRETARY OR BY THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY WHETHER IT
ACTUALLY MAKES SENSE WELL
THROUGH ON THOSE I THINK I COULD
SAY THAT WE WE THINK IT MAKES
SENSE WHY WE HAVE TO DO IS FILL
THE PROP ONE A STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS IN THOSE INCLUDED --
THIS REPORT WITHOUT DEPENDENT
ANALYSIS THAT IS SHARED WITH
THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE THIRD PARTY
VALIDATION OF OUR OKAY
UNDERSTOOD AND ELLIE -- JUST I
MEAN WHEN YOU WHEN YOU POINTED
OUT THAT.
THE MONIES ARE TO GOES UP TO A
POINT AND THEN WE DON'T REALLY
KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE LOOKS LIKE --
NEW BUT JUST.
THE ELABORATE ON THAT.
SURE SO THIS PLAN IDENTIFIES
FUNDING FOR THAT MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT AND THE
AUTHORITY IS INDICATED THIS IS A
BUILDING BLOCK APPROACH AND THAT
YOU KNOW ALTERNATELY I THINK THE
GOAL IS TO DO MORE THAN THAT.
AT THIS TIME ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
I THINK IT'S GONNA BE PRETTY
TIGHT JUST EVEN DO THE MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD -- AND THERE'S NO
FUNDING THAT'S BEEN IDENTIFIED
BEYOND THAT AT THIS POINT SO
THAT ASSUMES FOR EXAMPLE ALL THE
FUNDING THAT YOU KNOW CAP AND
TRADE FUNDING -- TO TWENTY
THIRTY SO YOU KNOW THAT'S SORT
OF WHAT'S IN CURRENT STATUTE IT
ASSUMES THAT WE KEEP THE FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT WE'VE THAT'S AT
RISK -- ADDED ASSUMES ALL OF THE
PROP ONE EIGHTY FIVE SO SHOULD
THE THE STATE WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH A SEGMENT BEYOND
MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD -- I SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SOURCES ARE
GONNA HAVE TO BE IDENTIFIED AND
THOSE COULD BE YOU KNOW PERHAPS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL WILL
CHANGE ITS TUNE ALTHOUGH AT THIS
TIME THAT'S ON CLEAR -- YOU KNOW
PERHAPS YOU KNOW OF OTHER ACTION
TO BE TAKEN BY THE LEGISLATURE
TO IDENTIFY OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES AND BY THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT AT THIS TIME
THERE'S THERE'S NO OR YOU KNOW
MAYBE PRIVATE SECTOR FUNDING
WILL COME AND BUT AT THIS.
POINT WE WE HAVE A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THAT.
IS THAT INTENTIONALLY TRYING TO
SORT OF LEAVE YOURSELF
FLEXIBILITY YOU OR OR IS IT THAT
THE MONEY'S JUST NOT THURMOND
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT.
THIS SORT OF UNCERTAINTY GOING
FOR IT I MEAN I WELL HOW DO I
GOING DOWN THE LOS ANGELES OR
DOWN TO SAN DIEGO OR DOWN TO
WHERE MOST THE PEOPLE IN THE
STATE LIVE WHO ARE STUCK IN
TRAFFIC ALL DAY HOW DO WE TELL
THEM THAT THE HIGH SPEED.
RAIL IS COMING AND THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO HELP THEM I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO TELL THEM THAT
IF THERE'S NO MONEY THERE --
WHEN IN?
THE ON OF I KNOW USING ONE ED
RIGHT BUT WHATEVER WE'RE NOT
HEARING WE'RE NOT HEARING G. G.
R. AFTER NOT HEARING SORT OF
ANOTHER PLANNED SO HELP ME OUT
HERE -- HAVE SILLY WELL IN A
WILL PART OF THIS PLAN IS IN
SOME RESPECTS MORE CONSERVATIVE
THAN THEM PRIOR PLANTS IN A
COUPLE WAYS.
SO AT IN THE PRIOR PLAN WE
TALKED ABOUT EXTENDING CAP AND
TRADE TO TWENTY FIFTY FROM
TWENTY THIRTY SO WE DIDN'T COUNT
THAT REVENUE IN THIS CASE WE
LOOKED AT THE AUTHORITY WE HAVE.
TO TWENTY THIRTY ON THE COST
SIDE -- WE INCREASE THE
CONTINGENCY BY ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS SO THIS IS A VERY
FOCUSED AND LOOKING AT THE MONEY
WE HAVE TODAY.
AND I THINK THAT PROJECTS AT A
STAGE WHERE DELIVERY IS CRITICAL
WE NEED TO DELIVER THE
CONSTRUCTION WE'RE DOING IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
ULTIMATELY DELIVER HIGH SPEED
RAIL TRAINS THAT ARE RUNNING ON
THE SEGMENTS TO DEMONSTRATE THE
VIABILITY OF THE PROGRAM.
SO THERE IS A BIT OF AN INCREASE
FOCUSED ON ON THOSE THINGS --
THE GOVERNOR SAID HE STILL HAS
THAT VISION OF THAT THE FULL
SYSTEM.
IT'S DIFFICULT -- TO MOVE
FORWARD WITHOUT A FEDERAL
PARTNER THAT'S INTERESTED IN
CONTINUING THE FUNDING I BELIEVE
IN THE FUTURE THAT'S GOING TO
CHANGE A AB NOT IMMEDIATELY.
BUT THERE'S MANY STATES THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN HIGH SPEED RAIL.
AND I THINK WITH THE CHANGING
TECHNOLOGY EDGED CHAIN IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR I THINK
HIGH SPEED RAIL MAKES EVEN MORE
SENSE.
AND YOU KNOW -- COMMUTER RAIL
ANOTHER RAIL SYSTEMS MAKE EVEN
MORE SENSE THAN EVER SO YOU KNOW
I I'M LONG TERM OPTIMISTIC THAT
TO YOU KNOW WE WE KEEP BUILDING --
BUT HAVING A AGAIN DEVELOPING
THAT INCREASED CREDIBILITY FROM
THE DELIVERY I THINK IT'S KEY
NOW AND SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE
FOCUSED ON THAT AT THIS POINT IN
TIME.
IN THIS QUESTION AT
ENVIRONMENTAL ADDITIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL APPROVALS ARE
ANALYSES NEEDED ON THE BOOK AND
SIDE OF THINGS.
CAN YOU COMMENT ON ON THAT ISSUE
DO YOU THINK THAT THERE'S I MEAN
HOW HOW MANY STEPS AWAY ARE WE
FROM ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO GO BACK
TO SEVEN CALIFORNIA LIKE THIS IS
DEFINITELY GOING TO HAPPEN AS
OPPOSED TO LIKE.
WE GOTTA WAIT FOR A NEW
ADMINISTRATION OR CHANGE THE
DATA TO THEIR OR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING MATERIALIZING LIKE.
OKAY BEYOND THE SECURING THE
FUNDING IS THERE ALSO AS
RIGOROUS Là SERVE MULTIPLE
HOOPS WE'VE GOT TO JUMP THROUGH
AND SEE CA OUR OTHER FRIENDS
RIGHT NOW.
WELL AS FOR THE LOS ANGELES
UNION STATION PROJECT TO THAT
INITIAL SCOPE THROUGH INITIAL
CONSTRUCTION HAS HAS RECEIVED
FULL FUNDING OF BOTH HROUGH THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL BOOK IN FUNDING
BUT ALSO THROUGH ONE OF THESE
THAT TRANSIT INTERCITY.
RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAM THE SP ONE
CAP AND TRADE GRANTS.
BUT IT IS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL STAGE RIGHT NOW --
LA UNION STATION.
AT OR AT LA METRO IS IS IS OF
THE YES THE SPONSOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS.
AND THEY HAVE -- GOING FORWARD
WITH AS HIGH SPEED RAIL HAS AT
WITH THIS SEQUEL FIRST STRATEGY --
SO THEY'RE PUT OUT THE SECRET
DOCUMENTS ADVANCING KNOWS --
THAT THERE ARE SOME DIFFICULTY
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS
GOING TO ASK IF ANY BUT YEAH SO.
SOME WAY TO YEAH I STREAMLINED
BASED ON SEEK WOULD IN THEORY IF
YOU COULD TEAR OFF THAT AND IT
IS THAT WHAT IT DID WHAT'S UP
THE MOST IS TO DO THEM AT THE
SAME TIME AND AND LACK OF
ENGAGEMENT.
BUT OF BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
BISCUITS CAUSING A RISK HERE I
IN INCLUDING THE LA UNION
STATION PROJECT THAT THEY'RE
PURSUING THE SEQUEL FIRST
STRATEGY TO ADVANCE THAT SIDE OF
IT.
I LONGER TERM -- WE HAVE -- AT
THAT I THINK MORE THAN A YEAR
AGO WAS SUBMITTED THE DOCK IN
THE INFORMATION TO THE FEDERAL
RAILROAD ADMINISTRATION.
REQUESTING NEPA ASSIGNMENT --
FOR CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
STREAMLINING MAJOR IT'S
SOMETHING THAT CALTRANS ENJOYS
FOR HIGHWAY AND ROAD PROJECTS
SINCE I THINK ABOUT.
TWO THOUSAND SIX AND IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS OF TIME
WHICH THEN RESULTS IN A
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS OF MONEY.
AND SO WITH FAT -- WE'VE APPLIED
FOR THAT UNFORTUNATELY ABOUT --
AUGUST OF LAST YEAR -- THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- REALLY
DISCONTINUED DURING THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL NEED FOR WORK ON
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT AND
HAS NOT GRANTED THE NEED BY
SIMON EITHER SO WE'RE WE'RE
STUCK RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S WHY
THE OBJECT UP A REPORT ED DID.
DEVOTE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF A
PRINT TO TALKING ABOUT FEDERAL
RISK.
SO I WOULD JUST WRAP UP AND
THANK YOU FOR THE INDULGENT
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND FOR YOUR
SMITH SECRETARY -- THE MORE WE
CAN DO I GET THE FEDERAL RISKS
THE MORE WE CAN DO TO SHOW SOME
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
FOR ALL THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THAT.
AT LEAST THAT THERE'S AN INTENT
AND I APPRECIATE WORKING ON THE
RUN THROUGH THEIR OTHER ISSUES
TO IN THE AREA ON THE BOOKENDS
RIGHT NOT JUST RUN THROUGH
THERE'S ALL THE UPGRADES THROUGH
THAT -- YOU KNOW VARIOUS LINES
GOING TO THE REGION -- I STILL
BELIEVE IN GETTING THE SAN DIEGO.
AND I I TRULY THINK I MEAN WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE FOUR FIVE
FREEWAY THAT IS THE MOST TRAFFIC
FREEWAY ON THE PLANET
CUMULATIVELY -- SO HELP US YOU
KNOW ANYTHING I CAN DO TO WORK
WITH YOU GUYS TO HELP WAS
ARTICULATE THAT VISION DOWN
SOUTH BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT THIS.
I JUST -- LOSE THE CONSTITUENCY
DOWN THERE I GET PROJECT
EXECUTION AND DELIVERY BUT
SOMEONE AT LEAST HAVE A
CONTINGENT PLAN OR SORT OF
ARTICULATING WHAT THAT COULD
LOOK LIKE IF SAY X. DOLLARS
MATERIALIZE OR EFFECTS FEDERAL
APPROVALS FOR GRANTED I THINK OF
BE VERY HELPFUL SO.
JUST FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION I
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU AND THANK CENTER
MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS SECTOR
GOOD TO SEE YOU THINK IS A MUCH
LA -- AS WELL AND BE QUICK IN
REGARDS TO I JUST WANNA CONFIRM
THE SAN JOAQUIN LINE.
YOU'RE STILL NEEDING TO BE
CONVERSATIONS TO BE A TO FLUSH
OUT.
LEASING OF THAT LINE RIGHT I AND
THEN ALSO -- WHAT HAPPENS?
TO OUR SENSES THAT WE PUT INTO
THAT LINE LONGER TERM SO HE JUST
BRINGS UP TO DATE ONE MORE TIME
ON THE SAN JOAQUIN.
ADELINE COME IN IN THE BAY.
SURE BUT THE I THINK IT IS A
LEADING TO THAT -- THE PROPOSAL
TO WORK WITH ALL THESE PARTNERS
SAID TO HIGH SPEED RAIL CANNOT.
RUN A SERVICE THAT REQUIRES AN
OPERATING SUBSIDY BUT THE
EXISTING COMMUTER LINES EXISTING
INTER CITY RAIL LINE'S TODAY.
I RECEIVE OPERATING SUPPORT AND
SO WHAT THE EARLY TRAIN OPERATOR
LOOKED AT WAS HOW THAT WOULD
CHANGE WITH AND WITHOUT HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
SO AG LOOKING AT BOTH A SAN
JOAQUIN'S AND THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL SERVICE AS WELL AS THE
EXISTING CONNECTING BUS SERVICE.
THE TEARS ESTIMATED THAT THE
OPERATING SUBSIDY WOULD ACTUALLY
FALL WITH THE ADVENT OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL SEWED FALL FROM ABOUT
EIGHTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR WITHOUT TO ABOUTSIXTY
THREE MILLION A YEAR WITH HIGH
SPEED RAIL BEING ADDED TO THAT
SECTION.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE RIDERSHIP
GROWS SUBSTANTIALLY AND SO WITH
THAT YOU HAVE A GREATER FAREBOX
RECOVERY.
AND THAT'S COVERING A GREATER
PROPORTION OF THE COST.
INDEED.
GO ON THE SAN JOAQUIN SAID THE
NINE HIGH SPEED RAIL SIDE I'LL.
SAY.
YOU THERE ARE STILL DISCUSSIONS
HAPPENING ABOUT THAT THAT LONGER
TERM LEASE CORRECT.
HE SAID LONGER TERM NEEDS LEASE
LISA I'M SORRY YEAH.
AB AT CORRECT YES SO -- YOU
THERE'S THERE'S ORE WORK TO DO
WITH THE PARTNERS BUT SOMEWHAT
ANALOGOUS TO THE THE CALTRAIN
STATEMENT.
IN THAT -- PROP ONE A ENVISIONS
OTHER A PASSENGER RAIL PROVIDERS
AT HAVING ACCESS AND USE OF THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND SO WE WOULD.
CONTINUE WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS TO SAN JOAQUIN CHASE ON
HOW THEY THEY COULD ACCESS THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL INFRASTRUCTURE
TO PROVIDE THAT SERVICE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOT A FOLLOW UP QUESTION ON MY
ADMINISTRATIVE CAP WITHOUT PROP
ONE A WE KNOW THAT THE YOUR CALL
AT SOMETIME GOING TO HAVE TO BE
COMING BACK TO US.
ON THE INCREASE OF THE CAP.
IF WE GO AHEAD AND WE MOVE
CONSULTANTS TO REGULAR STAFF
[inaudible]
YOU HAVE.
AT THE END THAT TIMING.
YES SIR -- AT OUR CURRENT ADMIN
BUDGET OF FORTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS -- E WILL ANTICIPATE
RUNNING OUT AT OUR CURRENT RATE --
FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE DO HAVE TO
WORK WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO FIGURE OUT A PLAN AND NOW WE
DO HAVE THE ABILITY TO INCREASE
OUR TWO AND A HALF PERCENT CAP.
THE 5%.
IF THAT'S THE CASE WE DO GET THE
5% IF WE KEPT AT THE FORTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR ADMIN BUDGET --
THAT WOULD PROBABLY GET US OUT
TO FISCAL YEAR [inaudible]
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN OKAY.
ALL RIGHT AND IN.
LET'S JUST PLAY A GAME ARE THE
CHAIR HERE HAS BEEN AN ADVOCATE
OF INCREASING THE ALLOWANCES ON
THE CAP AND TRADE.
I'M CONTINUE TO BE TENACIOUS OF
NICHOLS IS LISTENING ON THIS SO
LET'S JUST WALK ME THROUGH THIS
LET'S JUST SAY THAT I'M.
MORE WE'RE THE S. LEGISLATURE'S
SUCCESSFUL THAT THE CAP ENTRY
REVENUES GO FROM THREE BILLION.
SIX BILLION THEN TO NINE BILLION
SO THAT THAT THE HIGH SPEED
RAILS AUTHORITY GOES TO ANOTHER.
BILLION AND A HALF A YEAR.
OKAY LET'S JUST LET'S JUST SAY
THAT AND SO IF WE PROJECT THAT
OUT FOR TEN YEARS THAT'S FIFTEEN
BILLION.
WORTH SIXTY BILLION SHORT.
THE QUESTION WOULD BE I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE AN ANSWER RIGHT
NOW IS THAT THE SHORTFALL IS
STILL THERE EVEN IF EVEN IN.
THE CHAIRS MOST YOU KNOW
AGGRESSIVE.
A SCENARIO ONE HIGH SPEED RAIL
WHICH SHOULD BE A STEADY.
FLOW OF MONEY HOW DO WE CLOSE
THE OTHER FORTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR CASH.
VIOLENCE THAT'S THE FIRST
QUESTION AND IN THE SECOND
QUESTION WHICH I'M SURE MY
COLLEAGUES WHO I CAN ALWAYS SAID
SAID WHAT'S YOUR THINKING AND
THAT THE NEW -- PLAN WE'RE WITH
THAT.
EXTRA MONEY GO WITH THAT BE TO
THE BOOK IN ST LOS ANGELES THE
GILROY A SEGMENT.
OR TWO PALMDALE HEIGHT ON THE OF
WHAT WE DO IF YOU IF YOU ONLY
GOT A QUARTER OF WHAT YOU NEEDED
WHAT WOULD BE.
FROM YOUR ANALYSIS BECAUSE THEY
SEE ME TO LET YOU LOOK AT LOTS
OF SCENARIO SO THERE WAS THAT.
THE THE CITY ARE YOU CHOSE WAS
NUMBER ONE SO BUT NUMBER.
TWO ONE THREE HOW WOULD THAT
WORK AND WELL AS A GAMER PLANS
YEAH.
FIRST OF ALL I I WOULD TAKE THAT
INCREASING CAP AND TRADE
[inaudible]
AND COUPLE THINGS TO THINK ABOUT
SO LET ME TALK ABOUT WHAT WE
KNOW FOR SURE TODAY SO WE HAVE
TWO SCENARIOS ON OUR SIXTEEN
BUSINESS PLAN EIGHTEEN AND AND
THE CURRENT PROJECT OF THE
REPORT.
WEST MADE AT THE LOW END IF WE
WERE TO GET FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
IN CAP AND TRADE THE TWO
THOUSAND THIRTY WE WOULD HAVE
ABOUT TWENTY POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE ENTIRE PROJECT --
IF THAT CAP AND TRADE COMES IN
AT SEVEN FIFTY AND THAT'S OUR
HIGHER SCENARIO.
WE WOULD HAVE ABOUT TWENTY THREE
POINT FOUR FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT'S A PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE ENOUGH WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS
YOU CAN TO SEE HOW THIS
ACCUMULATES.
BUT THE CHALLENGE AGAIN WOULD
COME TRADE IS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
IT COMES IN AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU. TO ALSO LOOK AT
SOME TYPE OF STABILITY IN THE
PROGRAM.
BECAUSE THE FLUCTUATION OF CAP
AND TRADE A LITTLE DIFFICULT FOR
A PROJECT THIS LARGE.
WHEN YOU'RE WE MIGHT GET A BIG
BOX OF IT TWICE AS MUCH AS WE
PLANNED THE OTHER YOU KNOW
ANOTHER YEAR COULD COME IN QUITE
A BIT LESS?
SO OBVIOUSLY A HIGHER CAP WOULD
BE WONDERFUL FOR THE PROJECT IT
WOULD CLOSE THE GAP.
I'LL BUT I ALSO WOULD COURAGE
LOOK AT SOME TYPE OF STABILITY
AND THE FLUCTUATION OF WHAT WE
GET EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
THAT THAT'S REALLY THE KEY THE
TO BE ABLE TO PLAN THIS PROJECT
IS HOW MUCH.
ACTUAL CASH WE'RE GONNA GET PER
YEAR.
ABOUT GETTING INTO.
A GREAT DISCUSSION PART OF THAT
WAS THE EXTENSION TO TWENTY
THIRTY AND THE CUSHION OF TWO
THIRDS VOTE THAT PEOPLE THOUGHT
THAT THAT THE UNCERTAINTY WAS.
WAS RELEASED I GUESS THIS
FOLLOWING HIS VICTORY IN THIS IS
THAT IS THAT WHAT WOULD WHAT
SHOULD WE BE LOOKING AT IF WE IF
WE GO FORWARD WITH THIS --
DELIVERY OFFICE OF OF OPERATING
SEGMENT WHAT WOULD BE NEXT WERE
IN THE LOGICAL SEQUENCE AND WHAT
WHAT SHOULD WE BE LOOKING FOR
WAYS.
TALK TO THESE PEOPLE ON LOS
ANGELES ABOUT WHEN IT'S COMING.
BUT CERTAINLY ENTION TOO THAT --
THE CAP AND TRADE RISING IS SAID
MAYBE A RISING THAT WATER LINE
THEIR LIVES OTHER VOTES TO
INCLUDING HE HAD.
TRANSIT INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL
PROGRAM THAT RECEIVES MONEY
THERE SO.
YOU KNOW THAT THIS IS IT I THINK
FUNDED THE FOR EXAMPLE THAT THE
METROLINK ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE IN THE LAST ROUND
SO THAT THAT HELPS ON MULTIPLE --
SCORES -- BUT YEAH CORDY AT THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS PLAN I
LOOKED AT IT AGAIN THE VALLEY TO
VALLEY.
AND INDICATED -- THEY GET
WORRIED TO SANTA TO S. SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND THEN.
BRIDGING THAT GAP THAT.
TO GILROY -- TO THE MADERA GAP
AS THE WHAT'S CURRENTLY -- AT
THAT TIME WAS LISTED AS THE THE
MAJOR FINDING PEACE SO HE WANTED
TO FOCUS ON THAT.
AGAIN I I WOULD SAY IS YOU KNOW
STATEWIDE -- THE RAIL
MODERNIZATION APPROACH AND THE
THE INCLUDING ON OUR COMMUNITY
COMMUTER IN INNER CITY IS IS THE
RIGHT WAY TO GO BECAUSE FOR THE
SYSTEMS TO TO WORK AND ACHIEVE
THE AIR QUALITY BENEFITS THE VM
TO PRODUCTION YOU NEED A NETWORK
OF RAIL.
THAT CONNECTS TO EACH OTHER AND
AND HIGH SPEED ROSE THAT
BACKBONE.
BUT YOU NEED THOSE CONNECTING
PIECES TO GROW SIGNIFICANTLY AS
WELL.
JUST AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM NO
ACTION IS REQUIRED TO LET'S MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT WHICH
IS YOUR I. T. SECURITY REQUEST
OF FIVE PERMANENT POSITIONS AND
TWO POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN --
THE CURRENT -- FISCAL
[inaudible]
BUDGET YEAR.
THANK YOU DON WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST APPROVAL FIVE POSITIONS
AND TWO POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS A PROBLEM WITH A FUNDING
TO IMPROVE THE AUTHORITIES
INFORMATION SECURITY PROGRAM.
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE SECURITY
FRAMEWORK ESTABLISHED BY THE
CALIFORNIA INFORMATION.
SECURITY OFFICE.
OF THIS REQUEST RESOURCES WILL
ENABLE US TO IMPLEMENT NEEDED
TOOLS.
L. INCREASE OUR ABILITY TO
PROTECT THE STATE INFORMATION.
AND DEFEND AGAINST EVOLVING
THREATS.
WE WILL ALSO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY STAFF TO CREATE AND
MAINTAIN.
SECURITY AND GOVERNANCE AND
ESTABLISH AND MAINTAIN A DATA
LOSS PREVENTION PROGRAM
[inaudible]
I WOULD [inaudible]
QUESTION.
DO YOU HAVE A FILE.
NO CONCERNS WITH PROPOSAL.
OKAY.
I'M MEMBERS QUESTIONS.
ART LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM AT
THIS TIME.
WAITING.
FOR OUR COLLEAGUE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
YEAR ROUND WITH WIRE.
MINING.
A QUORUM IS ESTABLISH THIS IS A
APPROVALS BUDGET.
BUDGET IT LET'S OPEN THE PUBLIC
HEARING MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
LIKE TO COMMENT ON ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT SEEING THEM WILL CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING.
MOTION BY A SELLER MONEY TO
APPROVE AS BUDGET PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ASKING HI OWNS [inaudible]
WITH [inaudible]
ONE MORNING.
ALL RIGHT KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE TRANSITION OF THE I.
T. PROGRAM THANK YOU.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
APPROVAL FIVE POSITIONS AND TWO
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROP WHEN A FUNDING TO INCREASE
THE OPERATIONAL AND OVERSIGHT.
OF ABILITIES OF THE AUTHORITIES
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY OFFICE.
YEAH IT OFFICE PROVIDES CORE
TECHNOLOGIES SERVICES TO YOUR
FORTY INCLUDING DESKTOP.
ALL DEVICES SUPPORT EMAIL
SERVICES SERVER AND BACK UP
ADMINISTRATION.
NETWORK ADMINISTRATION AND
OVERSIGHT THE VENDOR SERVICES.
I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION SEEMS TO BE IN LINE
WITH THE AUDITORS --
OBSERVATIONS NEKOLIKO.
OKAY LET'S OPEN THE PUBLIC
HEARING THIS IS AYE ISSUE NUMBER.
NINE THE I. T. TRANSITION.
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING THAT
SAME.
THERE'S A MOTION BY -- SENATOR
MINING THIS IS APPROVED AS
BUDGET PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI JONES PLAN [inaudible]
MONEY.
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MANNER AND YOUR LAST
MATTER IS -- CONTRACT MANAGEMENT
AND FINANCIAL OFFICE RESOURCES
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER TEN YES
ISSUE NUMBER TEN THE ALL FOR A
STATE AUDIT RELEASED ITS REPORT
IN NOVEMBER FIFTEENTH OF TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN AND AMONG
OTHER FINDINGS FOUND THAT THE
FORTY SHOULD SHIFT.
CERTAIN WORKLOAD ACTIVITIES FROM
THE PRIVATE CONTRACTORS TO STATE
STAFF.
WELL THE AUTHORITY IS CONDUCTING
A BROADER REVIEW OF THE ENTIRE
ORGANIZATION.
THIS INITIAL REQUEST WILL REDUCE
OVERALL PROGRAM COSTS BY ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND CAN BE IMPLEMENTED QUICKLY
BY REDUCING TH NUMBER OF
CONSULTANT POSITION.
SUPPORTED ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS SPECIFICALLY IN THE
AREA OF CONTRACT ADMINISTRATION
AND MANAGEMENT.
AND THE FINANCIAL OFFICE REPLACE
THOSE CONSULTANTS WITH STATE
STAFF.
THIS REPLACE THIS REQUEST
INCLUDES AN INCREASE OF THIRTY
FIVE STATE POSITIONS.
AND FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROP ONE A FUNDING.
OFFSET BY THE REDUCTION OF
THIRTY FIVE CONSULTANT HAVE TV'S.
AND FIVE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THUS FREEING UP THE
CURRENT CONTRACT FUNDING FOR
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
SERVICES SUCH AS RAIL OPERATIONS
ENGINEERING AND INFRASTRUCTURE
DELIVERY.
YOU SEEN OUR STAFF REPORT WHAT
IS THE CURRENT VACANCY RATE THAT
YOU HAVE AND HOW.
WHAT'S RECALL MY HAND HERE AND
HOW WE'RE GOING.
TO FILL THE HAVE ABOUT FORTY TWO
VACANCIES IT COMES OUT TO ABOUT
19220%.
OUR VACANCY RATE TODAY IN --
I'LL YOU KNOW HISTORICALLY WE'VE
HAD WE'VE KIND OF HOVERED AROUND
THE 20% VACANCIES. ONE THING TO
KEEP IN MIND IS A FOR THE PAST
FOUR YEARS WE'VE INCREASED BY
70%.
YOU HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY
NEW POSITIONS OVER THAT FOUR
YEAR PERIOD -- THERE ARE SOME
POSITIONS THAT I'VE BEEN
SOMEWHAT CHALLENGING TO RECRUIT --
BUT THE POSITIONS THAT WE HAVE
HERE FOR THE THIRTY FIVE ARE I
WOULD CLASSIFY AS MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS.
THAT ARE MORE FREQUENTLY FOUND
IN STATE SERVIE.
OR THE ADMIN FOLKS.
THANK YOU HELLO.
WE HAVE NO SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
WE THINK IT'S REASONABLE TO
SHIFT SOME AS WORKLOAD
CONSISTING OF THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT FROM CONSULTANTS TO STATE
STAFF JUST WANTED TO KNOW THAT --
THERE IS AN AUGMENTATION BEING
MADE TO THE BUDGET THERE ISN'T A
COMMENSURATE SORT OF BUDGET
REDUCTION ON THEIR EXPECTING
THAT'S BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA
BASICALLY HAVE OTHER THINGS
THEY'RE GONNA NEED TO PAY THIS
AYE REAL DELIVERY PARTNER.
FOR AND SO THAT'S CERTAINLY
APPROPRIATE HOWEVER WE DO YOU --
THINK IT'S AN ISSUE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE GOING TO WANTTO
HAVE KIND OF AB CONTINUED
OVERSIGHT OVER TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE REALLY ARE REDUCING OUR
RELIANCE ON THAT CONTRACTOR --
AND AND ACTUALLY KEEPING THOSE
GOALS THAT'S A GOOD GUESS -- I
THIS IS THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
IS TO HOLD THIS MATTER OPEN
LET'S OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING IS
THE LAST MATTER WITH THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
WASHINGTON.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE BIG WITH THEIR ANDROID
ASSOCIATES FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS.
IN CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THIS REQUEST
HOWEVER WE DON'T THINK IT GOES
QUITE FAR ENOUGH -- BOTH THE
STATE AUDITOR AND A RECENT --
INVESTIGATION BY THE LA TIMES
FOUND THAT -- HIGH SPEED RAIL
FOR THE LAST DECADE HAS BEEN.
PRETTY MUCH OVER RUN BY PRIVATE
SECTOR ENGINEERING CONSULTANTS
THOSE CONSULTANTS FOR THEIR TO
HIRE ADDITIONAL CONSULTANTS TO
OVERSEE CONSULTANTS TO INSPECT
OTHER CONSULTANTS EXCEPT DURING
JUNIOR SHOULD BE BROUGHT ON
BOARD. TO DO DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION INSPECTION -- JUST
LIKE THIS WOULD SAVE MONEY. FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION SAME THING
WOULD HAPPEN ON THE ENGINEERING
IT'S AT LEAST TWO OR THREE TIMES
MORE EXPENSIVE FOR THESE PRIVATE
SECTOR ENGINEERS WE THINK THAT
THIS BUDGET SHOULD BE --
COMMENDED HAVE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
ENGINEERS AT THE AUTHORITY THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT.
LIMóN THING ABOUT HAVE THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES APOLOGIZE FOR THE
VOICE YOU CAN THANK MY SON FOR
THAT -- I JUST WANTED TO BOUNCE
OFF THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER AND
JUST REMIND EVERYONE THAT THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL CANNOT BE BOILED DOWN
TO ONE ISSUE OF CONSULTANTS
VERSUS STATE STAFF.
NOBODY DISCOUNT THE EXPERTISE
AND EXPERIENCE.
THE PRIVATE CONSULTANTS BRING TO
THE TABLE AND AGAIN.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL IS FACING A
PROBLEM WITH RETENTION AND MEN
OF A QUALIFIED STAFF WHICH
ACTUALLY IS A CHALLENGE FOR ALL
OF US BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
GRADUATE STEM EDUCATION SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY LET'S CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
I'M SEEING ANOTHER COMMENTS WILL
GET A HOLD THIS MATTER OPEN.
AND THANK THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY FOR THEIR PRESENTATION.
LET'S RETURN TO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR MEMBERS AND BEFORE WE
VOTE ON ITEMS I WILL I'M GOING
TO PULL ISSUE NUMBER TWO ON
ORGANIZED CRIME RETAIL TASK
FORCE.
FROM THE AGENDA WE WILL TAKE
THAT UP.
IN OUR MAY REVISE HEARINGS NEXT
WEEK.
MAY REVISE EVIDENTLY IS OUT SO.
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PROVISIONAL ONE WHICH WOULD BE
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
POSITIONS. TWENTY A ANY -- FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES AND EIGHTY EIGHTY
FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN IN ISSUE NUMBER THREE AS
BUDGET.
THIS IS JUST ISSUE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE THE VOTE ONLY COUNTER IS
THERE A MOTION.
MOTION BY SIX SENATE MCGUIRE
PLEASE CALL ROLE.
I CAN'T SPEAK HI [inaudible] ONE
MONEY.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU VOTE THE
VOTES AYE AYES HAVE IT FOR ONE
THOSE MATTERS ARE PROOF LET'S GO
BACK TO ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT AND THIS IS THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL THIS IS THE I. T. SECURITY
REQUEST THAT RECOMMENDATION WAS.
APPROVED AS BUDGET PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS JONES.
I CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU BOTH THE I
SEVEN FOUR ONE MATTERS APPROVE
NOW PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON ISSUE NUMBER NINE THE
I. T. TRANSITION REQUEST CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU VOTE THE
AYES HAVE IT FOR ONE THE MATTERS
OF PROOF SO LET'S GO TO BRING UP
CALTRANS AND THEN.
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR THIS IS PROJECT DELIVERY
WORKLOAD [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
MISTER CHAIR SENATORS ARE MY
NAME IS JIM DAVIS I AM THE
SPECIAL ADVISER TO DIRECTOR
BERMAN IT CALTRANS.
WITH ME IS CAR PAULSON OR
DIVISION CHIEF OF BUDGETS.
CALTRANS REQUEST AN INCREASE OF
EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION AND
FORTY EIGHT FULL TIME
EQUIVALENTS FOR PROJECT DELIVERY
WORKLOAD.
SCHOOL YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY PROPOSED GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES
INCREASING WORKLOAD TO DELIVER
PROJECTS TO ME SENATE BILL ONE
OR SP ONE REQUIREMENTS.
TOTAL WORKLOAD RESOURCES
REQUESTED AT THE TRADITIONAL 90%
STATE STAFF 10% CONSULTANT RATIO.
AFTER A DECADE OF DECLINING
WORKLOAD FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN MORE.
THE FIRST TIME MAJOR INCREASE IN
THE CAPITAL IS ABOARD.
COS PROGRAM DUE TO SB.
ONE CALTRANS DEVELOPED AND
EXECUTED AN AGGRESSIVE
RECRUITMENT PROGRAM TO MEET
INCREASED STAFFING NEEDS.
BY THE END OF THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR THE C. U. S. PROGRAM IS
ESTIMATED IT WILL SUCCESSFULLY
HIRED ALMOST FIFTEEN HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES. TO MEET WORKLOAD
NEEDS.
THE TOTAL RESOURCES REQUESTED
ALLOW CALTRANS TO PRESERVE AND
IMPROVE ON THE HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INVESTED IN
THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
WHICH IS THE FOUNDATION OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMY ENABLING
EFFICIENT MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE
GOODS AND SERVICES.
WITH THIS PROPOSAL THE COS
PROGRAM ON WILL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE ITS COMMITMENT TO
DELIVER PROJECTS TO CONSTRUCTION
AND OVERSEE THE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS CURRENTLY FUNDED OR
EXPECTED BE FUNDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION.
OR BY OUR LOCAL PARTNERS.
RESOURCES CONTAINED THIS REQUEST --
CRUCIAL COMPONENTS IN THE
DELIVERY OF TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS AN INSURER THE
CONTINUED ECONOMY AND LIVABILITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
NOW AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS.
RECALLING THE LA ON A SECOND BUT
THEY WERE A LITTLE SURPRISED ON
THESE OUT YEAR INCREASES THAT
YOU HAD COULD YOU.
ANTICIPATE THE QUESTION AND
COMMENT ON THAT.
SURE MISTER CHAIR -- AS WE DID
IN LAST YEAR'S FINANCE LETTER
WE'VE PROJECTED -- WITH THE
DOUBLING THE SIZE OF THE SHOP
FROM SENATE BILL.
ONE BILLION TO SUBMITTED NEARLY
A THREE THOUSAND F. T. E. --
INCREASE OVER THE NEXT NUMBER OF
YEARS AND WE PROJECTED THAT ON
OUR FIVE YEAR AHEAD PROJECTION.
I AND WE CONTINUE TO SHOW THAT
SAME PROJECTION IN THE CURRENT
FINANCE WATER.
AND THAT IS DUE TO THE INCREASED
NUMBER OF DOLLARS AN INCREASED
NUMBER OF PROJECTS GOING OUT
THERE.
TO PLAN DESIGN AND CONSTRUCT THE
PROJECTS [inaudible]
HELLO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST
COMPUTERS AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND SO AS YOU
NOTED AND THAT WAY I THINK THERE
WAS SOME INITIAL SURPRISE AYE
AYE HE DID NOT HAVE THE BENEFIT
OF REVIEWING THAT PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT STAFFING INCREASE.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED IN
THE CURRENT YEAR -- THIS SO JUST
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHER
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND I THINK
THERE WAS AS MAYBE SOME ELEMENT
OF SURPRISE FOLKS GET EXPECTED
WE CONTINUE TO GO UP BUT MAYBE
NOT.
I'M QUITE SO DRAMATICALLY OVER
THE DEPARTMENT HAS PROVIDED
THOSE OUT YOUR PRODUCTIONS THAT
THEY PROVIDED LAST YEAR AND IT
DOES SHOW THAT SO I'M NOT
ENTIRELY AWARE OF THE
CONVERSATIONS AND AND WHERE SOME
OF THAT CAME FROM.
AND RELATIVE TO THIS I REQUEST
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THE NINETEEN TWENTY AND PROPOSAL
IT'S A RELATIVELY MODEST
INCREASE.
AND AS WAS STATED IT'S AND FORTY
EIGHT FULL TIME EQUIVALENTS
WHICH AMOUNTS TO ACTUALLY
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE STATE --
STAFF POSITIONS THIS IS
BASICALLY JUST BRINGING DOWN THE
AMOUNT OF OVERTIME IN INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF STAFF TO SORT OF
MORE OF THE HISTORICAL LEVELS
AND NOW THAT.
THE DEPARTMENTS OUT OF THAT
IMMEDIATE YOU KNOW NEED TO BRING
ON ADDITIONAL RESOURCES RIGHT
I'M AFTER THE PASSAGE OF SB.
ONE AND WE DO THINK THAT THIS
YEAR OF HAVING A PRETTY MODEST
INCREASE PROVIDES A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE --
TO GET MORE INFORMATION OF
BEFORE AND POTENTIAL REQUESTS
FOR FUTURE INCREASES COME DOWN
THE LINE AND THE NEXT YEAR OR
TWO OR THREE ON TO THE EXTENT
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT MAYBE
ANOTHER YOU KNOW THOUSAND TO TWO
THOUSAND POSITION REQUEST -- AND
THAT'S BECAUSE IN THE PAST OUR
OFFICE HAS A HANDSOME AND
CONCERNS I'M ABOUT THE BUDGETING
METHODOLOGY IN THE PROJECT
ESTIMATING MASSIVE METHODOLOGY
USED BY CALTRANS.
AND AN IMPASSE REVIEWS FOUND
THAT THERE'S A TENDENCY TO
OVERSTATE THE NEED FOR RESOURCES
AT THE TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
HAD A WORKING GROUP THAT HAD --
SIMILAR FINDINGS AS WELL.
IN RESPONSE TO THOSE CONCERNS
MANY CHANGES AND IMPROVEMENTS
HAVE BEEN PUT INTO PLACE SO THE
DEPARTMENT HAS TAKEN A NUMBER OF
STEPS -- INTERNALLY TO IMPROVE
THEIR AND THEIR BUDGETING
PROCESS TO IMPROVE THEIR I'M
DATA TRACKING AND THE ACCURACY
OF THE INFORMATION THAT'S IN
THERE SYSTEM THAT WILL TIMIDLY
RESULTS IN THE AMOUNT OF THE
ANNUAL BUDGET REQUEST.
ON THE LEGISLATURE THROUGH THE
INACTIVE ENACTMENT OF ON SB ONE
AS WELL AS OTHER LEGISLATION HAS
GIVEN THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION THIS ROLE IN DOING
PROJECT LEVEL OVERSIGHT -- WHERE
YOU HAVE AN OUTSIDE INDEPENDENT
ENTITY NOW?
OVERSEEING -- MUCH IN THE SAME
WAY THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT DO FOR
OTHER CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
AND BECAUSE CALTRANS IS SO LARGE
IN THE NUMBER PROJECTS IS SO
GREAT YOU'RE NOT GETTING CAPITAL
L. A. B. C. PIECE TO REVIEW FOR
EVERY PROJECT.
THAT'S MORE AND A SORT OF A A
CAT IN LINE WITH THE FUNCTION
THAT THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION -- PERFORMS IN
ALLOCATING TO SPECIFIC PROJECTS
SO WHAT WE WOULD ACTUALLY
RECOMMEND IS THIS IS A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY TO GET MORE
INFORMATION WE RECOMMEND THAT
YOU ADOPT SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE.
REQUIRING THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION -- TO DO A LOOK BACK
ANALISIS ON A SAMPLE OF PROJECTS
ESSENTIALLY LOOKING AT WHAT IT
THE DEPARTMENT ESTIMATE IT WAS
GOING TO NEED HOW DID THAT
CHANGE OVER TIME AND WHERE DID
WE ACTUALLY.
I AM AND THAT COULD BE VERY
HELPFUL ON IN A NUMBER OF WAYS
NOT ONLY IN FORMING COS BUT JUST
I MEAN AN UNDERSTANDING -- WHAT
AT THE TIME LINES AND COSTS
CHANGES LOOK LIKE FOR PROJECTS
OVER TIME ON AND THEN THEY COULD
COMPARE THAT TO THE AMOUNT THAT
WAS REQUESTED IN THE BUDGET FOR
THOSE PROJECTS FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS?
UNDER SB ONE CALTRANS HAS TO
SHOW WHAT 10%.
EFFICIENCY SAVINGS THAT THE THAT
THE GOOD TO THE ONE ON TO
DELIVER YOUR PROJECTS IF I
RECALL BUT IT VOTED ON ONE
HUNDRED YEAH A HUNDRED A HUNDRED
MILLION EACH YEAR SO THEY
THEY'VE GOT TO REPORT.
TO US INTO CTC TTC ANY WAY THAT
THEY'VE GOT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN SAVINGS YEARS SAYING
THAT THE WE WANT THEM TO LOOK
BACK.
AT THESE PROJECTS AND SHOW
ADDITIONAL SAVINGS OR JUST. TO
THE CONNECT THE DOTS AND HOW
THEY GOT THAT SAVING YOU THINK
IT'S MORE CONNECTING THE DOTS IS
NOT NOT NECESSARILY SHOWING
SAVINGS BUT LOOKING AT I'M
REALLY GETTING TO THE ACCURACY
OF THE ESTIMATES.
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS WHY AND
CAL TRANS OR THE PROJECT
MANAGERS ARE SOMEWHERE
INCENTIVIZE WE HAVE A MISALIGNED
INCENTIVE. FOR THEM TO OVER
ESTIMATE THE BUDGET -- IF
THEY'RE BEING HELD THE COMING IN
HONOR UNDER BUDGET AND THEY YOU
KNOW S. ESTIMATORS MIGHT BE
SOMEWHAT CONSERVATIVE WHEN
THEY'RE THINKING ABOUT THE
AMOUNT THAT THEY NEED.
AND THE AND IN ADDITION IF
CALTRANS HAS TO GO TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION EVERY
TIME THERE'S A CHANGE -- AND
THAT'S AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
THEY PERHAPS I DON'T WANT TO DO
AND SORT OF A HIGHLIGHTS IF
THERE'S AN ISSUE WITH THE
PROJECT WORK JUST TAKES
ADDITIONAL STAFF AND A SHELL
TIME.
SO THERE AND THE IN PAST REVIEWS
AND LOOKING AT HOW THE ESTIMATE
PROJECT BUDGETS I'M A FOR
SOMEONE.
UNDERSTANDABLE REASONS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT'S PERSPECTIVE THERE
DO SEEM TO BE SOME OF THESE
INCENTIVES FOR THEM TO OVER
ESTIMATE WHAT IS NEEDED AND SO.
WENT WHEN THOSE SAME ESTIMATES
ARE THAN FEEDING INTO THINGS
LIKE BUDGET REQUEST IT BECOMES
VERY CHALLENGING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO KNOW WAS JUST THE
RIGHT AMOUNT TO RESIST TOO MUCH
AND HOW DO WE THINK ABOUT IT AND
SO.
HAVING SOME OF THAT INFORMATION
NOW THAT YOU'VE TASK THE CTC
WITH DOING THIS PROJECT LEVEL
OVERSIGHT WE THINK THIS IS A
GOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM.
TO TAKE THAT OVERSIGHT AND THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY'RE
COLLECTING AND REPORT BACK IN A
HELPFUL WAY AND MY UNDERSTANDING
ON THE HUNDRED MILLION IS THAT
AND THE IT IF THAT'S SORT OF A
SEPARATE.
PIECE -- AND THAT THAT WHAT'S
BEING REPORTED THERE MY IN OF
IDENTIFY CERTAIN PROJECTS
SAVINGS BUT NOT NECESSARILY
LOOKING AT THE ACCURACY OKAY.
THANK YOU I'M.
QUESTIONS MEMBERS HAVE.
OKAY THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS
HOLD OPEN WE HAVE YOUR NECKS
ITEM ON THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL THEN I'LL HAVE
THE PUBLIC HEARING ON BOTH.
ISSUES FOUR AND FIVE LET'S HAVE
A THE GENERAL.
COME ON IN.
THIS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
GOOD IN GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRPERSON AND CENTERS.
I AM NOT THE GENERAL HI.
THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF
INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF AUDITS
INVESTIGATIONS.
YOU'RE IN ORTEGA WAS APPOINTED
TO OVERSEE THE AS THE DIRECTOR
OF CAL HR AND SO SHE'S LEFT US
UNTIL I'M -- CURRENTLY
OVERSEEING THE INDEPENDENT
OFFICE OF ALL TO INVESTIGATION.
AND I HAVE WITH ME TODAY JEAN
CHEER WHO IS THE CHIEF COUNSEL
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION.
SO THE INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF
OURS INVESTIGATIONS OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION REQUEST LANGUAGE
BE ADDED TO THE ROAD REPAIR AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THAT AFFORD
SIMILAR PROTECTIONS OF
CONFIDENTIALITY.
CURRENTLY PROVIDED BY STATUTE TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR AND
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
OFFICE OF STATE AUDITS AND
EVALUATIONS.
THE ROAD REPAIR AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CHAPTER FIVE
STATUE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN VESTED
THE O. I. G. WITH FULL AUTHORITY
TO EXERCISE ALL RESPONSIBILITY
FOR MAINTAINING A FULL SCOPE.
INDEPENDENT AND OBJECTIVE AUDIT
AND INVESTIGATIVE PROGRAM.
HOWEVER THE SPECIFIED POWERS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES IDENTIFIED IN
SB. ONE FOR THE ID DID NOT
PROVIDE FULL ACCESS TO
INFORMATION OR THE PROTECTION OF
INFORMATION DEEMED CONFIDENTIAL
BY LAW.
THE INTENT OF THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION IS TO ENSURE THAT
BOTH THE IG AND THE LEGAL
DIVISION OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION.
ARE ABLE TO CONDUCT THIRD
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATIONS
WITHOUT FEAR OF COMPROMISING
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION. TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS WE ARE PROPOSING
HARMONIZING THE AUDITING
STATUTES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR.
THE OFFICE OF STATE AUDITS AND
EVALUATIONS AND THE OFFICE OF
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
THIS PROPOSAL LANGUAGES SIMILAR
TO THE PROTECTIONS ALREADY.
STATUTORILY PROVIDED TO THE
STATE OTHER AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IS OFFICE OF STATE
AUDITS AND EVALUATIONS.
IF CONFIDENTIALITY OF DOCUMENTS
CANNOT BE PROTECTED IT WILL
HAMPER THE O. I. G.'S ABILITY TO
CONDUCT COMPLETE AND THOROUGH
AUDITS AND INVESTIGATIONS.
A LINE IN THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY.
LANGUAGE IS NOT INTENDED TO
BROADEN THE AUTHORITY OF THE O.
I. G..
BUT TO AVOID POTENTIAL CONFUSION
BETWEEN VARIOUS STATE AUDIT
STATUTES.
THE CURRENT STATUTES REFERENCE
IN SB ONE PERTAIN TO THE AUTO
RESPONSIBILITIES -- THIRTY
ASSOCIATED WITH AN INTERNAL
ESOS THAT AUDIT PROGRAM WOULD BE
AFFORDED THE CONFIDENTIAL AT HIM
PROTECTIONS OF THAT DEPARTMENT.
HOWEVER BECAUSE SB ONE
SPECIFICALLY CREATED THE IG TO
BE INDEPENDENT OF THE APARTMENT.
THE INTERNAL AUDITING STATUTES
IN SB ONE ARE NOT APPLICABLE TO
THE EXISTING INDEPENDENT OFFICE
OF AUDITS.
AND DO NOT ADDRESS THE
PROTECTIONS INC OF CONFIDENTIAL
RECORDS OR COMMUNICATIONS.
THEREFORE THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE
WOULD PROVIDE THE FOLLOWING.
A COMMON UNDERSTANDING AS TO
WHAT DOCUMENTS ARE SUBJECT TO
AND WHICH ARE EXEMPT FROM
DISCLOSURE.
WHICH WOULD BENEFIT BOTH THE IG
AND THE DEPARTMENTS LEGAL
COUNSEL.
IT WOULD AVOID CONFUSION BETWEEN
WHAT CAN OR CANNOT BE PROVIDED
TO THE O. I. G..
U. I. G. AND THE DEPARTMENT CAN
FOCUS MORE RESOURCES ON THEIR
CORE MISSIONS RATHER THAN ON
DISCLOSURE DISPUTE.
AND BY PROMOTING PUBLIC
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
ARE A CORE VALUE FOR BOTH THE IG
AND THE DEPARTMENT.
IN SUMMARY THE PURPOSE OF THIS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS TO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
CAN'T AND CAN CONTINUE WITHOUT
COMPROMISING.
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION.
WITHOUT THE ASSURANCE OF
CONFIDENTIALITY THE IDEAS UNABLE.
TO PROTECT CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION OBTAINED FROM THE
DEPARTMENT NECESSARY TO PERFORM
THE RESPONSIBILITIES OUTLINED IN
SB.
ONE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OVER GENE THAT YOU MAY
HAVE AT THIS TIME EVEN THE SO I
THINK OF FROM UNDERSTAND THERE'S
INTERNAL AUDITS VERSES.
EXTERNAL AUDIX I GUESS THAT
WOULD BE THE OPPOSITE AND
ARSINOE STAFF REPORTS INDICATING
THAT THE THE GENERAL HAS THAT
RIGHT TO IF HE BELIEVES THAT
THAT DISCLOSURE IS GOING.
TO BUT THIS IS POTENTIALLY --
EXPOSE SOMEBODY TO RETALIATION
OR THE FEAR OF RETALIATION THAT
SHE CAN SHE HAS THE AUTHORITY
RIGHT RIGHT NOW [inaudible]
I'M.
THIS IS A BROADER.
YOUR SCOPE THAN JUST THE THREE
YELLING INTERNAL AUDIT SHOP BE
BASICALLY BEFORE SB ONE RIGHT
REPORTED TO THE DIRECTOR -- OF
THE DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION
AND AS SUCH AS AN INTERNAL LOT
OF SHOP I WAS ABLE ALSO TO BE
AFFORDED THE PROTECTION ALSO THE
CONFIDENTIALITY BE NEVER SHARE
INFORMATION.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT LEGAL
COUNSEL NOW AS AN INDEPENDENT
ORGANIZATION ONE OF THE CONCERNS
THAT -- THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
YOU'RE IN ORTEGA HAD AND ALSO
JEANS YEAR WAS WE ARE NO LONGER.
AFFORD THOSE SAME PROTECTIONS OF
THE CAN THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF
INFORMATION.
SO I DON'T KNOW I'M HOPEFUL I'M
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTION TO BUT
THERE ARE IN IF YOU LOOK
SPECIFICALLY THE STATUTES THAT
ARE IN SB ONE AND WHAT THEY'RE
OUTLINED THEIR ALL WORRIES
FOCUSED ON AN INTERNAL LOT OF
SHOPPING ORGANIZATION.
WITH YOU WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
STATE AUDITOR'S -- LEGISLATIVE --
LANGUAGE AND ALSO THAT OF SAY
THOSE ARE VERY SPECIFIC TO AN
EXTERNAL TYPE ORGANIZATION BE
ABLE TO GO IN AND ASKED FOR AND
RECEIVE DOCUMENTS AND ALSO BE
ABLE TO MAITAIN THE
CONFIDENTIALITY THOSE DOCTORS
LIKE A DISCLOSURE YES.
LEO TO HAVE.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THE PROPOSAL OBVIOUSLY HAVING A
WELL FUNCTIONING -- INSPECTOR
GENERAL AND HAVING THAT
OVERSIGHT MECHANISM IN PLACE
WOULD BE -- A GOOD IT SAYING IT
AND WE DIDN'T HVE A SPECIFIC
CONCERNS WITH THE LANGUAGE YOUR
STAFF AS YOU INDICATED ALREADY
IS NOTED SOME CONCERNS OF DOES
IT GO TOO FAR IS IT REALLY
NEEDED AND WE WERE HAPPY TO HELP
AS YOU SORT THAT OUT I AM
ANOTHER OPTION.
IF YOU WANTED YOU COULD PURSUE
THIS THROUGH A POLICY PROCESS
AND HAVE THAT ADDED TO THE
POLICY COMMITTEES THAT THAT TAKE
A LOOK AT THOSE THINGS CLOSELY
AND BUT IT'S REALLY UP TO THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IF YOU WANT TO
PURSUE THIS THROUGH THE BUDGET
OR THROUGH POLICY AND WE'RE
HAPPY. TO HELP YOU I GOT A WEEK
YOU KNOW THAT EXCELLENT.
MEMBERS THAT SING ANY QUESTIONS.
MY INTENTION IS TO OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING ON ISSUES NUMBER
FOUR AND FIVE SINCE ISSUE SIX
JUST INFORMATIONAL.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON EITHER
FOUR OR FIVE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THE BIG WITH THEIR
NEED ASSOCIATES FOR THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS.
IN CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT.
WE SUPPORT THE VERY MODEST
CAPITAL OUTLAY SUPPORT REQUEST
OF FORTY EIGHT POSITIONS BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY WE WANTED.
TO COMMEND AND THING CALTRANS
FOR THE HUMANS WORK THEY DID
LAST YEAR ON HIRING THE FIFTEEN
HUNDRED POSITIONS THAT REALLY
DID TAKE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
WORK THEY HAD TO BE CREATIVE.
GO OUT TO THE UNIVERSITIES AND
AND RAMP UP AND SO WE JUST
WANTED.
TO THANK THEM FOR THAT
[inaudible]
EXCELLENT.
ALRIGHT LET'S CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING.
ISSUES NUMBER FOUR AND FIVE OR
GREATER KEEP THEM OPEN THANK YOU
FOR THE CLARIFICATION ON ON THAT
AND LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR LAST
ITEM -- BAY AREA STORMWATER
PERMIT VIOLATION ISSUE NUMBER
SIX THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
ITEM.
WELCOME BACK.
ALL THINGS LEAD TO CALTRANS
PROPERTY.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR CENTERS JIM DAVIS
SPECIAL VISOR DIRECTOR BERMAN A
CALTRANS WITH MS CLARK PAULSON
DIVISION CHIEF OF BUDGETS.
CALTRANS HAS THE DIFFICULT TASK
OF ADRESSING TRASH ON OUR ROADS.
THIS IS TRAVIS A CALTRANS DOES
NOT CREATE BUT IS GENERATED FROM
EXTERNAL SOURCES SUCH AS
LITTERING.
ILLEGAL ENCAMPMENTS ILLEGAL
DUMPING.
AND REFUSE COMING OFF TRUCKS
THAT ARE NOT TOO HARD HEADED
DOWN THE HIGHWAY.
TRANSCANADA IS ROAD IS THE
RESULT OF A PERVASIVE SOCIAL
ISSUE THAT REQUIRES INCREASE
PUBLIC AWARENESS.
AND ENGAGEMENT.
CALTRANS EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
TRASH ON OUR ROADS INCLUDE
FUNDING PUBLIC OUTREACH
CAMPAIGNS. TO THE TRASH PROBLEM
IS ADDRESSED AT ITS STORES.
CALTRANS WORK HARD TO COMPLY
WITH A STATEWIDE STORMWATER
PERMIT INCLUDING ADDRESSING
TRASH AND RUNOFF FROM CALTRANS
RIGHT AWAY.
CALTRANS SHARES MUTUAL GOALS
WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
WATER QUALITY BOARD OR REGIONAL
WATER BOARD.
IN ENHANCING THE ENVIRONMENT
ENHANCING IN ENSURING TRASH DOES
NOT REACH CALIFORNIA'S WATER WAY.
CALTRANS TRASH CONTROL EFFORTS
INCLUDE CONSTRUCTION OF TRASH
CAPTURE DEVICES ON ROADSIDES IN
MANUAL TRASH CLEAN UP EFFORTS
THROUGH ITS MAINTENANCE PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS PROMOTING PUBLIC
AWARENESS.
TRASHCAN UPS HAVE BEEN
INCREASING IN THE BAY AREA FOR
EXAMPLE.
CALTRANS IS GOOD INCREASED AS
LITTLE REMOVAL EFFORT IN
EXPENDITURES FROM APPROXIMATELY
NINE MILLION IN. TWENTY THIRTEEN
TO MORE THAN TWENTY THREE
MILLION LAST YEAR.
DURING TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALTRANS
WORKER THREE TOOK WATER BOARD IN
THE STATE WATER BOARD TO RESPOND
TO A DRAFT CEASE AND DESIST
ORDER.
OR ORDER.
THAT IMPOSES REQUIREMENTS FOR
CALTRANS TO IMPLEMENT EXPEDITED
TRASH CONTROL MEASURES IN SAN
FRANCISCO BAY REGION.
THE PLAN WAS DEVELOPED WITH THE
WATER BOARD STAFF AND WENT FOR
TOO ATTENTIVE ORDER.
AT THE FEBRUARY TWENTY NINTH
REGIONAL WATER BOARD MEETING.
HOWEVER AT THAT HEARING THE
REGIONAL WATER BOARD ADOPTED IN
ORDER THAT SETS REVISED SHORTER
TIMELINE FOR CALTRANS
TEMPERAMENT TRASH CONTROL
MEASURES IN A SIGNIFICANTLY
LARGER AREA.
AND THE TENTATIVE ORDER.
CALTRANS HAD AN IMPLEMENTATION
APPROACH WITH THE TOWN OF ORDER.
BUT SINCE THE NEW ORDER REQUIRES
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE ACRES OF
TREATMENT.
A NEW WORK PLAN IS BEING
DEVELOPED WITH THE REGIONAL AND
STATE WATER BOARD.
CALTRANS IN IN THE WATER BOARD
SHARE THE GOAL TO DEVELOP A WORK
PLAN THE BOW SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCES TRASH MAN.
DOES NOT IMPACT CALTRANS ABILITY
TO MEET STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM
PERFORMANCE MEASURES.
ESTABLISHED BY THE ROAD REPAIR
AND ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OF 2017%
A BILL.
ONE SUCH AS PAVEMENT AND BRIDGE
REPAIR.
WE'RE HAVING PRODUCTIVE MEETINGS
WITH THE REGIONAL STATE WATER
BOARDS TO DEVELOP A WORK PLAN TO
IMPLEMENT THE ORDER.
THE PLAN WILL INCLUDE APPROACHES
SUCH AS THE AMOUNT OF EFFORT AND
ACRES OF CREDIT PROVIDED OR
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS INSTALLATION
OF TRASH CAPTURE DEVICES.
COOPERATIVE EFFORTS WITH LOCAL
STORM WATER PROJECTS.
MANUAL TRASH CLEAN UP IN PUBLIC
SERVICE CAMPAIGNS TO REDUCE
LITTER IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WE'RE WORKING TO FINALIZE THAT
PLAN THIS SUMMER.
NOW AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS.
THE QUESTION.
IT THERE WAS TWENTY FIVE ACRE OR
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND ACRES THAT --
THE RIGHT AWAY REGION THE THAT
THE THAT THE ORDER CAME DOWN
FROM THE REGIONAL BOARD WAS THAT
AN EXPANSION OF WHAT THE INTERIM
ORDER WAS A YOUR PRESENTATION
WAS.
AT A HAS THE AIR OF A AT A
MASSIVE EXPANSION OF WHAT THE
INTERIM WATER WAS VERSUS BUT THE
THE ACTUAL ORDER WAS SURE THE
TENTATIVE AGREEMENT THAT WE HAD
WAS AT THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED
ACRES.
OUT AND WHEN THE BOARD CAME BACK
IT.
INCREASED TO EIGHTY SEVEN
HUNDRED ACRES [inaudible]
OKAY.
L. A. L. DO YOU HAVE ANY
INSIGHTS ON THIS PROBLEM
[inaudible]
SENATE MCGUIRE.
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE THAT MISTER
DAVIS IN COMMITTEE ME -- THIS IN
DISTRICT FOUR SIR -- I'M
[inaudible]
BOTTOM LINE.
BROUGHT THIS ISSUE UP.
IN A PREVIOUS HEARING ABOUT
STAFFING SHORTAGES.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS AND
NEGOTIATIONS ABOUT LOOKING AT
SOME TYPE OF REGIONAL IMPACT ON
PAY [inaudible]
BY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT WE'VE IN THAT
THAT CALTRANS IS INVESTED MORE
TO BE ABLE TO PICK UP ADDITIONAL
LETTER TRASH.
ALONG THE CORRIDORS BUT JUST
BEING ABLE TO GET FOLKS OUT
THERE HAS BEEN A REAL CHALLENGE
AS WELL AND YOU ALL BEEN ABLE.
TO COME UP WITH SOME INNOVATIVE.
IDEAS BUT YOU TALK TO US ABOUT
HOW THIS IS GONNA WORK LONG TERM
BECAUSE THIS IS BEEN ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES.
ESPECIALLY THOSE ENTRY LINE
WORKERS AGAIN THE MAN HIRED AND
THEN CAME IN THE RETAIN.
YOUR MIND.
TALK ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THAT'S
GOING TO BE PART OF THE RECIPE
FOR SUCCESS SURE SENATOR.
IS THE SUCCESS OF US MEETING THE
THE IS NOT DEPENDENT ON US WILL
HAVE THE PEOPLE AND STAFF ON
BOARD TO GET THE WORK DONE AND
SO -- AS YOU STATED WE'VE HAD A
DIFFICULT TIME IN IN THE BAY
AREA PARTICULARLY IN IN THE
MARIN AREA IN IN YOUR AREA.
OF VOTE RETAIN THOSE INDIVIDUALS --
THE ADMINISTRATION IS LOOKING AT
OPPORTUNITIES -- FOR NEGOTIATION --
WITH THE UNIONS -- FOR RETENTION
TAIPEI ALL OF THAT WAS THINGS
THAT WE'VE DONE -- WITH OF
ARGUED NINE AND LOOKING AT THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS -- WITH OUR MAINTENANCE
AS WELL.
YEAH I LOOK AT AND I'M NOT GONNA
GET IT DO A DEEP DIVE ON TO THIS
BUT I THINK.
I'M.
WHERE THERE WAS REGIONAL
DIFFERENCES REGIONAL DIFFERENCES
HAVE BEEN RECOGNIZED IN OTHER
UNITS?
THE CHALLENGE WITH THE REGIONAL
DIFFERENCES IT IS [inaudible]
A BULLET.
AND I'M ALL CHARACTERIZES A FEW
HUNDRED BOX.
I AM NOT IS NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
ATTRACT FOLKS BE ABLE TO GET IN
I THINK.
AGAIN WE'RE GONNA NEED TO HAVE A
LONGER TERM CONVERSATION.
WHILE THIS IMPACTS THE NORTH BAY.
SAN JOSE'S IMPACTED BY THIS LOS
ANGELES IMPACTED BY THIS IS A
REALLY NEAT PROGRAM SET DISTRICT
FOR IS INTRODUCED AS FAR AS
GETTING INDIVIDUALS ARE COMING
AT A PRISONER IN JAIL.
IN THE MAIN JOB GETTING THE
STATE EMPLOYMENT WHICH IS
FANTASTIC.
I'M WORKING WITH THE MAYOR AND
SALAS A DOWN THERE ON THAT.
AND BEING ABLE TO RETAIN IT'S
JUST BEEN A CHALLENGE SO I'M I
UNDERSTAND YOU ARE.
HUSTLING.
THIS IS NOT AN OFFER ON STONE'S.
IN AT THE SAME TIME THOUGH.
IF WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
HIRE ENOUGH FOLKS WHERE TO GET
THE JOB DONE.
LIKE TO BE TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE A COMPLY
ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT
[inaudible]
HI.
I HAVE TO GET BACK TO CENTER
RIGHT ON I GET EMAILS YEAH AND
AGAIN THIS IS NOT THE FAULT OF
CALTRANS CALTRANS HAS BEEN.
HUSTLING TO BE TO GET THIS DONE
I AS FAR AS TRYING TO GET FOLKS
HIRED AND HAVE SOME RECOGNITION
ABOUT REGIONAL DIFFERENCES IN
PAY BECAUSE IT'S ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL.
I GUESS THE THE QUESTION THEN.
IS BEGGING TO BE ASK IS WHAT'S
THE RELATIONSHIP DID YOU HAVE
WITH THE OTHER PUBLIC PARTNERS
THIRD THERE YOU GET NO THE CITY
OF OAKLAND.
AND IT'S IT'S IT'S GRAN HAVE THE
WATER -- VIOLATION ON CALTRANS
BUT THIS IS ANGIE SOME PROPERTY
THE COUNTY FELLA MEDIA IN A THE
CITY OF OAKLAND THE FLOOD
CONTROL DISTRICT EAST BAY PARK
THE SORT OF OF THE A HODGE PODGE
OF PUBLIC AGENCY IN.
AND THE HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS ARE
THERE YOU KNOW IT [inaudible] TO
THINGS ARE LEFT BEHIND.
MY GREAT TO THE CALTRANS
PROPERTY JUST HAPPENS TO BE THE
WAY THAT THE THE WATER FLOWS HOW
LONG HOW IS THAT ARE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE NEXT STEPS THAT
YOU'RE TAKING TO COMPLY WITH
THIS -- ISSUE AFTER YOU WORK
WITH THE REWORKING THE WORK PLAN
THEY AT THAT THE REVISED WORK
PLAN HOW DOES THAT COOPERATION
IF THERE IS COOPERATION I GUESS.
MR SURE AS YOU SAID IT IS A
PERVASIVE PROBLEM NOT JUST ON
CALTRANS RIGHT AWAY BUT ON OUR
LOCAL PARTNERS RIGHT AWAY AS AS
WELL -- WE WORKING VERY WELL --
WE HAVE WITH OUR OUR PARTNERS --
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE -- STARTING
THIS WEEK WEEKLY MEETINGS AT
STAFF LEVEL -- AND THEN KNOW
ONCE A MONTH AT THE EXECUTIVE
LEVEL -- AND MYSELF AND MY
COUNTERPARTS IN THE OTHER BOARDS
ALL WE ARE MEETING AT EXECUTIVE
LEVEL TO BREAK DOWN BARRIERS AND
RESOLVE ISSUES TO KEEP MOVING
THIS FOR TO GET THIS WORK PLAN
DONE.
BY THIS SUMMER WELL AS REGARDS --
TO PARTNERING WITH OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS WE DO HAVE ABOUT THIRTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS AND LOCAL
PARTNERSHIPS AGREEMENTS THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW IN THE BAY AREA
WITH A LOCAL PARTNERS.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE WOULD
PARTNER TOGETHER AND US
CONTRIBUTE MONEY TO OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS WHERE OUR TRASH IS
MAYBE GOING ON TO THEIR LOCAL
STREETS AND ROADS -- THROUGH
THEIR WATER WAYS -- AND DOING
COMBINED -- TRASH COLLECTION --
DEVICES TWO SO WE JOINTLY
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AND SO.
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR IS WHAT
KIND OF CREDITS DO WE GET FROM
THE BOARD FOR DOING THOSE TYPE
OF ACTIVITIES IN SO WHEN YOU GET
TO THE EIGHTY SEVEN HUNDRED
ACRES IT'S GETTING DWN.
TO ALL THE DIFFERENT -- THINGS
THAT WERE WORKING ON TO ADDRESS
THIS WELL WHAT ARE THE CREDITS
WE GET FOR EACH ONE OF THOSE AND
THAT'S WHAT'S UNDER THE
NEGOTIATION CURRENTLY.
OKAY THAT'S THE THIS VIOLATION
ALL RIGHT LET'S OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING MEMBERS OF HE
PUBLIC THAT ARE HERE THIS IS THE
INFORMATIONAL ITEM ON THE BAY
AREA.
STORMWATER PERMIT VIOLATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN DAVID
LEWIS EXECUTIVE RECORD SAY THE
BAY THANK YOU FOR A CHEN ISING
THIS ITEM AND ITEM SIX ACTUALLY
POSES ALL OF THE RIGHT QUESTIONS
IN YOUR MEMO TODAY.
AND I HAVEN'T HEARD ANSWERS TO
ANY OF THEM SO I'M I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF ITEMS THAT --
YOU MENTIONED AND THEN MAKE SOME
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS -- FOR
YOUR ACTION ON THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR.
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN JUST
HIGHLIGHTED THE THE INTERSECTING
OBLIGATIONS OF CITIES AND
COUNTIES WITH CALTRANS ACTUALLY
FLOWS IS THE OTHER WAY TOO
BECAUSE THE TRASH THAT CALTRANS
IS NOT INTERDICTING FROM GETTING
IN THEIR STORE.
ARE COUNTING AGAINST THE CITY'S
LIMITS THEY ARE UNDER LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS TO REDUCE THEIR
TRASH BEFORE IT GETS INTO CREEKS
THE BAY IN THE OCEAN.
AND THE FAILURE OF CALTRANS TO
DO MORE SOONER IS ACTUALLY
IMPACTING THOSE CITIES THAT HAVE
THAT MANDATE.
AND I JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE
THAT THIS IS NOW A REQUIREMENT
UNDER LAW.
AND YOU AND OTHER LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS THE GOVERNOR HAVE ALL
SAID THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
GOING TO BE SECOND TO NONE IN
ENFORCING.
WATER POLLUTION LAWS INCLUDING
FEDERAL LAWS THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS ACTUALLY
ATTACKING AN UNDER CUTTING.
AND THIS IS THE LARGEST STATE
AGENCY THAT IS VIOLATING WATER
POLLUTION LAWS SO IF.
IT DOESN'T MEET THESE TARGETS
THAT ARE NOW LAID OUT IN THE
CEASE AND DESIST ORDER.
WE ACTUALLY IN OUR IN THE
UNENVIABLE POSITION OF ONE STATE
AGENCY THE WATER BOARD HAVE A
POTENTIALLY HAVING TO ISSUE
FINES AND PENALTIES AGAINST
OTHER STATE AGENCY.
NOW NOBODY WANTS THAT.
WE NEED THIS.
MATTER DRESSED.
IN A SO I AT MINIMUM -- IN THE
IN THE IN THE NEXT SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME NOT THIS SUMMER YOU NEED
ANSWERS. TO THE QUESTIONS THAT
YOU POSED TO CALTRANS.
IN IN SPECIFIC ARE THIS YEAR YOU
NEED FOR THE BUDGET TO CLEARLY.
DEDICATE AND DESIGNATE.
WHICH POTS OF MONEY CALTRANS IS
AUTHORIZED.
AND COMMANDED TO USE TO ADDRESS
THIS POLLUTION PROBLEM IT'S NOT
OPTIONAL TO MEET THESE TARGETS.
V. BUDGET SHOULD DESIGNATE ALSO
THAT THE FUNDS THE CALTRANS
HOUSE IN THE SHOP PROGRAM OR IN
OTHER ACCOUNTS.
CAN NOT ONLY BE USED FOR CAPITAL
EXPENSES TO INSTALL THESE TRASH
CAPTURE DEVICES OR EQUIVALENT.
BUT ALSO FOR THE OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE THE ONGOING
MAINTENANCE OF THESE DEVICES
OVER TIME AND THE CLEANING OUT
OF THESE DEVICES DURING THEIR
LIFESPAN.
IF THERE'S ANY QUESTION AT ALL.
OF FROM THE GSA OR OTHER
ENTITIES THAT DETERMINE WHAT
FUNDS CAN BE USED FOR WHAT
PURPOSES THAT NEEDS TO BE
SPECIFIED SOMEWHERE IN THE
BUDGET LANGUAGE.
THAT THOSE FUNDS CAN BE ACCESSED
FOR THESE POLLUTION REDUCTION
OBLIGATIONS.
AND IF THAT GOES BEYOND THE SHOP
FUNDS AND IT SHOULD ALSO
DESIGNATE THAT.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T HAVE ANOTHER
YEAR OR TWO YEARS OF DELAY.
THE FIRST SET OF TARGETS IN THE
CEASE AND DESIST ORDER THAT
CALTRANS NEEDS TO MEET TO TREAT
TWO THOUSAND ACRES OF ITS RIGHT
OF WAY.
IS A YEAR FROM NOW IN JUNE.
AND FOR THOSE MEMBERS WHO ARE
NOT REPRESENTING THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS EVER BECAUSE THIS
IS A PREVIEW OF COMING
ATTRACTIONS.
THESE ARE OBLIGATIONS TO REDUCE
POLLUTION FROM ROADWAYS.
NEED TO HAPPEN STATEWIDE.
THIS IS A BAY AREA ISSUE RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE OF THE CEASE AND
DESIST ORDER FROM THE REGIONAL
WATER OARD.
BUT THIS IS AN ISSUE FOR THE
STATE WATER BOARD THIS ISSUE FOR
CALTRANS STATEWIDE.
SO I AM A BIT DISTRESSED AT THE
OF SOME OF WHAT YOU'RE HEARING
THIS MORNING FROM CALTRANS
REPRESENTATIVES BECAUSE THEY'RE
STILL TALKING ABOUT PUBLIC
EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS.
AND TEACHING PEOPLE NOT TO
LITTER AND THAT'S OF COURSE
IMPORTANT BUT THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE THAT THAT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING THE TRASH
OR INTERDICTING IT FROM GETTING
IN THE WATER WHICH IS CALTRANS
OBLIGATION.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE PUBLIC
AS EDUCATED OR NOT.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR CHEN ISING
THIS ISSUE AND I URGE YOU TO
ADDRESS IT IN THOSE SPECIFIC
WAYS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
LANGUAGE.
THANKS [inaudible]
MY CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING AND
ACTUALLY GET BACK TO THE WHEN
THE QUESTIONS THE STAFF POSED ON
THE BUDGET IMPACT AND THEN.
WHAT YOU THINK IS GOING?
TO TAKE TO COMPLY WITH THAT.
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU'RE
CHANGING YOUR WORK PLAN RIGHT
NOW SO IT'S A A MOVING TARGET.
BUT DE IMPACT THAT THEY HAVE.
AT LEAST IN THIS BUDGET YEAR TO
MEET THE THE CHARGE THAT THE
NOTICE VIOLATION HAS BEEN.
LEVY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF BASED
ON OUR PRELIMINARY DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE BOARDS.
WE THINK THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
MEET THE TWENTY TWENTY TARGETS
ARE LIKELY TO MEET THE TWENTY
TWENTY TARGETS WITH OUR CURRENT
BUDGET RESOURCES SO NO
ADDITIONAL RESOURCE.
AND IS THAT IT WOULD THERE'S A
REQUEST REPORT DISCARDED BE IN
THIS WHAT'S THE TIME LINE ON
THAT THAT WAS FROM LAST BUDGET
SURE.
THE STATUS OF THAT REPORT IS --
AS WE STARTED MEETING WITH THE
BOARDS -- ON THE TENTATIVE CEASE
AND DESIST ORDER.
WE REALIZE THAT TO BE COMPLIANT
WITH THAT LEGISLATIVE REQUEST
FOR THAT REPORT WE NEED A PATH
THAT WORK PLAN -- WE THOUGHT WE
HAD THE BASIS OF THAT WORK PLAN
BUT WHEN IT WENT TO THE WATER
BOARD THE REGIONAL WATER BOARD
THAT -- FELL APART.
AND SO OUR INTENT IS TO PROVIDE
THAT REPORT WHEN WE HAVE THAT
WORK PLAN IN INCLUDE THAT WORK
PLAN.
IN THAT RIVER.
OKAY SO BIG PICTURE BECAUSE OF
THIS IS A PROBLEM IN IN THE BAY
AREA AND THIS IS WHERE THE
VIOLATION IS.
WE'RE IN SAN LUIS OBISPO OR
SANTA BARBARA OR OTHER PLACES
THAT WILL BE HERE ARE IMPACTED
BY TRASH THE COMES OFF OF THE
CALTRANS WHAT'S WHAT'S THE BIG
PICTURE.
WITHIN WITHIN CALTRANS THAT WILL
POINT TO ADDRESS THIS.
IN ON COMPLIANCE ISSUE
[inaudible]
I THINK.
PRECEDENCE WE SAT WITH THIS WORK
PLAN.
ARE AND YOU ALWAYS CAN COUNT THE
BAY AREA FOR DEATH THAT THAT
HELP.
BOB IN THAT WILL BE EXTENDED TO
THE OTHER REGIONAL WATER BOARDS
THROUGHOUT THE OKAY BECAUSE IF
IT NEEDS TO BE SEPARATE IN THE
BUDGET SO THAT WE KNOW THAT THIS
IS THE OF THE FOLKS THAT'S YOU
KNOW THAT'S IT IS WHAT IT IS
THIS IS.
WE SET UP THE LONG FOR THIS IS
THAT THERE'S ARE DESIRABLE
OUTCOME.
AND YOU KNOW WHERE IT'S
APPROPRIATE TAKE TO GET THE
COLLECTORS AND THE MAINTENANCE
AND ALL THAT ALL THAT STUFF WITH
THE LABOR.
PEACE.
LET'S JUST GET IT DONE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL MATTER WE HAVE
CONCLUDED OUR BUSINESS OF THE
DAY.
AND WE'RE TURN